[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo what's going on
it is the ninja talking to you
i got 100 guns 100
i'm from new york new york
i'm in my new york bag today what's
going on y'all
hustling motivate what's up what's going
on lydia master mitch mitchie dies a lot
what's going on frodo drew money what's
up man
gaming fire you already know adams you
already know
lmx stand up why yo you already know
what it is
it's for the city yeah exactly
exactly there's a difference between
people who are a cohesive unit
and care about the craft versus a
fashion show
and i'll leave it at that but salute to
the dips now i like the dips though
the dipsticks but um yeah they got they
got dragged
deaf mobile what's going on oh man
what's going on play nyc
fam i see y'all seen a lot of y'all
yesterday that was really cool
man we got a fun fun show we're gonna
see what's going on
realm will pull up um yeah we gotta see
what someone saw man he's not feeling to
us so send us off some love
he may or may not be able to make it but
uh we got some people pulling up we
hopefully got some people pulling up um
should be fun the king will be in the
building should be in the building
livewire games what's up man i see you
on twitter acting up
no doubt good to see you good to see you
no doubt man but yeah we got some fun
we're going to talk a little recap
of what happened for the city you know i
had to throw it up for my city
and um yeah we got a couple of games to
talk about
katie what up yeah yeah you know we're
talking and um
what else goes to shima we gotta talk
about you know king gonna have his bars
for sony
during that sony topic but uh yeah
that's what i
got so we're gonna run and go get some
people in here
have some fun on the lord's day
but it's good to see y'all up in here
early talk about it lunken lunker
what's up haven't seen you in a minute
what's going on all right y'all i will
be back
all right see i gotta come back for leon
you can't be in here with no met slander
we slipping right now we don't be coming
in here no mess slam
mods get them now i'm just joking
[Music]
i'm gonna get the mods if i don't feel
it you good you're good
but just be easy on that best lady we
down right now it's a sensitive topic
gerald mack what's up or hella iop you
already
know put the crest up put the crest up
i'll be back for real this time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
[Music]
that i'm very spoiled to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta messed up and turn me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just
[Music]
um
[Music]
you ain't got to say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tiller uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being a cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch the snacks in
the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for attic if i can
imagine this cooler give you some advice
and invite your girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny worth the cognito
who cares if you fly if
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can never still
be the king of the statues
since a juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't
it nothing it's cool and it's beautiful
we let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's
[Music]
oh day god you're ridiculous and
we are live welcome
to the islands podcast comma llc
and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 220
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date and today we've got play nyc
2021 back for blood open beta
go some sushi about legends and
playstation plus
subscribers to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
so we got the four so we got the the
three
oh we got the two horses
yes we got more
[Laughter]
no no shout out to the lords man
hopefully addict will pull up soon we'll
see
if he's okay and soft said some love to
solve as well not feeling well but maybe
maybe get a little cameo later we'll see
but of course
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the excess gamer
ooh the prophet of xbox soon to be swami
whoa
swami king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing incredible baby
you understand what game pass did this
week
okay so yo i i didn't think that i was
gonna go first so fast
even though
[Music]
[Laughter]
turbo with the diamond in it and it died
yes oh my god i'm gonna
literally do the show then with it with
a turbo
a green black turban with a green
diamond got a lot of people
upset with these predictions yeah but my
name gonna be swami
really real stuff like that because
dudes is upset because they know my
predictions is crazy
so when they start to call me
real quick before you get into it real
quick shout out to the homie 108 dragons
tv
5 super chat good afternoon lords i'm at
play and why
still repping my guys shout out kings
little queen zoom call on deck
saturday love is back black brother
facts
thank you brother i appreciate that like
i said people go out there schedule time
uh so my daughter can get these
interviews that is fantastic all right
so
what we got all right i i downloaded
lumini's
uh the remaster i love that game i have
that on my playstation vita
it was probably one of my greatest games
on the playstation that took me away the
music was banging
and now i got it on on the big stream
it's like it's like texas we are
but you know it's i just like the flow
of it i like the music i like how the
game is set up
um curse of the dead uh gods
okay all right that's dead cells dlc
okay so i'm thinking it was dead cells
dlc from massage scrolling joint just
like before i didn't even bother to look
at the trailer
i downloaded it top down isometric game
okay i'm like what the hell is that
that's not my death house
and then you don't get uh weapons
it's different it's a it's a curse based
game so like you
let's say you pick one thing and you use
health hair to get strength hair
yeah so it's really different okay um
i was definitely playing you know my
ascent
trying to finish my um dragon yeah
seeing you i seen you on your dragon's
class i see you right i'm proud of you
with that you are committed
no no i love rpgs what people really
don't understand you know they like to
claim that they rpg kings and all this
other crap they just got to the show
they just got to the party
[Laughter]
i've been doing this i've been doing
this since these one and two i've been
doing
fantasy
when you didn't have platinums
when they throw their platinums into
your face or you are you are you are you
wanna
get out of here with your fake
accomplishments you wait so much nothing
so you implied with it when the young
boys try to step to you with the
achievements of the score pull up your
score
did that be nothing to it don't you hear
you just got your console you ain't even
doing day one sleepover get out of here
they was outside out waiting for that
playstation when i heard these stories
they'd be like here my mom's got nah
bro i got me and they were like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa who was you oh
when i got my 2600 i was eight years old
oh he's talking talking so i don't
i look at these dudes like weirdos
you're a weirdo you talk about your
platinum get out of here
but but at the same time i really
am one of those rpg nut dudes like i
find a weird rpg and i sit in there and
i'll play it if the mechanics actually
fit right but i respect good gameplay
good storytelling
and at dragon quest 11 and i've and i've
died from microsoft to
actually get these japanese rpgs inside
game pass
so if you're not playing them because
the next thing i'm going to do is
that you cruise the series you please
what is that i'm going from there
in the building yup judy got his hands
up yes yes because
at the same time we can't ask for things
and don't play things because somebody
jumped to my party the other day
was like oh you know i don't know man
there's nothing to play i said boy boy
boy get off my timeline it's it's too
much this is
to play it's the time right i'm playing
curse that
and i talked about it on gas show
yesterday shout out to you dudes
at play ny i i've never had so much fomo
in my life
and i was supposed to be there this is
what happened guys i was supposed to be
there
and i got i went to go get my shot right
so me not knowing i'm always thinking
it's three weeks because
i was supposed to go get the fights a
shot there was no fizer shot there
so they had the modern gosh i got the
modern almost died the next day
because you weren't sick deaf you were
just really messed up definitely i had
every symptom on the page
so like when they said you had the
chills i felt like i was butt [ __ ] ice
cream
done like if they said muscle legs i had
my eyeball muscles ache
like my whole body ate like my knee you
had all the symptoms
every every something they said i had it
when they said and maybe because i'm a
hypochondriac
[Laughter]
and you know i know the day it's
saturday so i go and i say yeah my third
week is how it was
going in that monday i went in that
monday fresh face off the gym i got
there
so old chicky was behind the uh the
glass
so i'm like yeah so she was like she's
seeing an iron lord shirt so she's
smiling
i'm loving them i love the recognition
even though they don't know what it is
they don't know what it is i know i go
from i'm gonna talk to you we're gonna
talk about we get to the place like just
he's official security
somebody said that to me so i thought i
was security continue
so she was like oh okay um what do you
have i'm sorry i'm you know getting my
second shot
she said oh okay cool let me see let me
look she's like oh my god you you're
early
i said huh i said it's been three weeks
she's sitting on my dirner's four yeah
we've done this for a second
so i'm like i have the event on saturday
to go through
i said and you know we're supposed to be
there she goes oh what adventure going
through i'm like oh play nyc
so i'm like yeah so she like oh what do
you do
whoa i'm like you know i do a podcast oh
when she podcasts follow me on the dip
right yeah there you go there you go
hit the like button hit the subscribe
button yeah yeah get that boot
yes share that out to your friends
so so she like oh okay okay so listen
this is what i can do for you mm-hmm
saturday we open up at nine o'clock i
could pop you early oh
and i'm like you know all right cool i'm
like all right cool i'll be there nine
o'clock nice and smooth
so then i call you and i talk to you and
i'm like yo i got an emergency
yeah yeah we had to be there eight
o'clock yeah
so i didn't get the
don't play with it i'm glad you didn't
do that because at the end of the day
you got to get the
body yeah do it exactly yeah you early
shot yeah dude you breaking protocol
let's let's focus on protocol
guys smoke the lemons in the chat you
know cause he's actually what i was like
look don't we
we rather us be safe and do it right you
know what i'm saying
i'm getting it on monday tuesday night
and then i saw y'all popping off with me
we're gonna get to it we're gonna get to
it
get to it yeah i was like yo nas
understood how i felt
because now i was put out of king
disease too shout out to knowledge of
the king disease too he put it out for
me because i was feeling kind of down
and stuff
so i had something to listen to but then
i saw your video i was like
we got more tough fun stuff for the top
you're gonna see
but real quick i seen i think it's one
of the lords pulled up
and analog that remember so let's start
with the lord first is that
is that is that the the wolf is that he
you're right my voice is all messed up
oh bad brother you should have told me
i'll go back to bed
let's go hold it down but it's up to you
i mean not that i've thrown you out
but if you rock it you're gonna get an
intro if you rock it
out how you feeling i'll i'll be fine
no [ __ ] yeah
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how
with the bad throat young wolf my man
lord addict how we doing sir i'm gonna
go back to bed yeah
he's like okay now bro i appreciate it i
appreciate it get better
let's us off get better we will hold the
realm
down in your honor and i appreciate you
for trying to make the old college
traveler get some respect
please so let me get this super played
with mcsearch yeah
and of course my man lorenzogamer.net
own play nyc's own
gene schaffmeyer or do i always butcher
it
safe buyer shop i did it again right i
think i think john shaffe and oscar
shaft buyer shot yeah john
you should never mess up his name
because you got to always know what
starts with the shaft pulse
yes you know what is i think because i
was i'll be about feelings to say it
[Laughter]
so i got i just gotta commit i gotta
commit to the chat
oh yeah i gotta come here it's a b issue
it's a b
issue let that go yeah bye what's going
on how you doing man yeah good king we
really missed you yesterday we needed
your charm to uh
bully avalanche a little bit there to
give us the details you should have seen
it yeah
yeah we no we want to film good cop bad
cop what's going on with the microsoft
acquisition
mm-hmm it to us yeah we needed our goon
presents we have our good goon presents
that we normally have on deck
yeah i'm sorry guys uh
i i i i was trying but modern wasn't
listening you're good you're good you're
good
at the same time i didn't get a chance
to tell gene jane did a tribute
um to the late biz markey if you didn't
get a chance to check out
his instagram i did not know he was so
musically inclined oh i did not know it
it took me aback right because i don't
really be on instagram like that but i
clicked on his
his timeline and i had i think i reached
out to you like oh my god that was
amazing
like you put a tear in my eye and
he played it he oh baby
oh he did it i was like uh
i'm getting goosebumps right now just
thinking about it back my old college
days i'd get drunk at house parties and
find some piano and
play it like sarcastically but then it's
been so well so i played kind of slowly
on the piano the day he passed away
and king saw that you did he did the
just a friend you did it justified
oh that's what's up that's a classic it
was so lit
um i i think i i think i reached out to
you i don't know i don't know sometimes
you know i look at people's stuff and i
should be like wow now i just sent a
heart out but yeah i think i had to say
something i don't i don't know but it
was really amazing and i
had to say it because i think this is
the first time i saw you since then so
yeah that's what's up
hey i'm sorry there's a nice five minute
video of me trying to upgrade the solid
state drive on my ps5 on there right now
nice i got to check that out dude
i know we were in in the cutting on the
field on the battlefield yesterday but
have you got a chance to play anything
this past week
um oh slow-mo
yeah i finished up death's door
when that came out did the review of
that
i'm just trying to get ready for
everything that's about to hit us
there's a huge wave coming
yeah i'm trying to platinum or really
just finish yakuza like a dragon yeah
so when judgment comes out no doubt i'm
gonna go back and revisit
tales of rosaria and tales of prosperia
to get ready for tales of a rise coming
out so i'm just working through that a
little bit of mlb the show
and the left four dead nice theta which
i know we're going to talk about yeah
yeah
we're going to get to and i see dps has
pulled up
is that the legendary slo-mo yo what up
what up what up
i know that v i know he i don't i don't
i don't even like there was a zoom right
yeah you don't have to get the avatar
yeah brother but dps in the building
scumcast in the building how you doing
sir
i'm doing pretty good man hope you guys
having a great sunday afternoon i'm just
here
to to see the tomfoolery
was harassing her oh yeah i did hear
about that oh yeah thank you
thank you harass her all you want that's
what i love
we did another raid together i had to
rest oh
have you been playing sir have you been
playing anything oh man i've been
playing everything anything and
everything let me see i i finished
scarlet nexus
finally i finished you wedo story loved
it like scarlet next is right now my
favorite game of the year
so far let me ask you a question with
that starlight message how how is the
rpg story elements to it like it's it's
it is a very short it's
very anime it's very animated so it's
like
you you'll see a lot of characters that
get thrown at you
and and the story goes all over the
place but
if you the characters are very in-depth
and
and interesting and do their builds on
the characters as well
yes yes okay there is character growth
with a lot of them and
and you know you get your typical
archetypes this is one guy named sheed
and he's just
awful like like the worst dude ever like
everybody opens his mouth is just like
can i punch this guy
later on you start to see some growth
with him you start to see like the shell
kind of
come down okay more of a not necessarily
a sympathetic figure he's still kind of
a dick
but okay you still you understand him a
little better and so it's like
it it has a good story more like amazing
he's more like sasuke yes yes yes okay
all right but like the combat so
basically
this game is what i wanted astral chain
to be oh
yeah that's what i saw i saw okay it
looked like it was uh like
like an astro chain type of uh open
fighting
you know elaborate
amazing yeah i like what you could bring
stuff to you and
it's a lot going on with the combat so
there's two main protagonists there's
urido and kasani they both have the same
power although it's not like say like in
uh ratchet and clank where you got two
different characters that are very
different but they play exactly the same
right both of them play differently and
you you know they play different
but and they have this telekinesis kind
of power they call it uh
uh psychokinesis okay but what's really
cool about the combat is that you have
these teammates with you they all have
their own power
and you can kind of like it's this
ability they call sas you can connect
with them
and then you can use their abilities in
conjunction with your own
so like to do sheeting i mentioned
before he has
uh electricity i can connect with him
and then when i start attacking i'm i'm
using that electricity with my attack
it's really cool
the way they set that up and then you
can also kind of
uh have them actually target a
particular enemy
you can change their their combat
behavior it's great it's great
okay yeah
that's awesome man you know somebody
playing that i've been playing last stop
you guys played last stop yet
oh my gosh i downloaded it i because i
was speaking to ren
and um i was like damn this looked like
a telltale kind of
flavor so i was thinking i don't know i
haven't tried it yet wait it does have
those elements to it
am i am i confusing with it is that the
one we ride from train stop to train
stop
and you have to maintain the train to
get there is that oh no no no
the this it has the fight
right like it is okay no no that's not
the game yeah you're almost like you
so it's three different main stories
there right right
and and it's like it's really weird
stuff going on with people disappearing
and people body like freaky friday body
swaps and
all kinds of stuff but it's wild the
story is really wild each
i i streamed it on twitch each story
like it starts off like
okay this is a little bit interesting it
just gets crazier and crazier and
crazier
but the cool thing is kind of like you
ever remember the movie crash
oh yeah yeah so basically yeah i know
what you're talking about yeah yeah
all these completely different stories
but these people intersect with one
another
or the like the people that they know
yeah
i like stuff like that so i might do
that yeah i might do it
it's in game pass definitely check it
out oh you'll know that you know i'm
there
you already you already know shout out
fulfilled dominance maximus really
we're giving out just free he did that
for you
exactly let me get these super chats
real quick um
let me get brad basement radio arcade uh
salute lords salute flip flop oh my god
besties next one let's go that's horror
shout out to horus
5 super chat uh let me find out king
still
talking about no ps console real talk i
believe him
though sony never wanted to go
all digital until they seen the the
one that's i i'm glad you said that
because i'm you must have watched me
talking on gas show
uh yesterday yeah i never thought that i
would see a
digital playstation until they saw how
much money microsoft made from only
digital console
and then they saw the level of revenue
because they never wanted to disrespect
the distributors
and that digital
console flies in the face of tradition
directly in the face of tradition
because you're getting a hundred percent
of your profits right then and there
and that is an upfront purchase that's
automatically uh
deposited in your bank account who does
not want that level of zell
for this i love it though you go hard
first got it like you know you know what
it is like
somebody oh you owe me 20 bucks all
right when i see you i got you
all right okay not now but you'll hit me
with that zelda paypal okay cash app or
whatever whatever that
hit you and it pop up you like oh i like
this
imagine sony like yo all right so um
i'm gonna pick up a final fantasy 7 next
week and
um uh but we got a digital sale oh let
me let me buy that right now
i like this
salute to the lord's king were you able
to get your escalade
i ordered mine won't show up until next
year okay no
no escalating i was not able to get my
ex because i was not able to get 10
playstations at the
launch that was all predicated on that i
wanted to actually
take the whole escalade coupe of cash
and then take my truck and just walk
over there and just walk out no money
down boom bad head
and just here you go thank you
playstation and i was gonna have a
playstation hat
i was gonna have a sony why is
playstation funding your escalades
what is going on what's going on because
that's what they were like
no games time
hustling skis the playstation lucious
augustus with the ten dollar super chat
[ __ ] because of you i started yakuza
like a dragon then play kiwami kwami 2
and yakuza zero playing control now as
of you closer break
shout out to game pass the book of acts
no drag gee do you approve of this uh
yakuza love yeah i think a great place
to start is zero on game pass and if
you're not going to start in game pass
or you don't you'll want to you want to
try something a little different uh
start with judgment is also a great
place to start but start with zero and
start with um
uh judgment there's a there's a moment
in like a dragon
that really kind of beckons back to zero
yeah i could tell it felt like a
callback and i'm like i didn't play this
and i know whatever's happening right
now
feels epic so i can only imagine for you
that hit
different and i i don't want to spoil it
but yeah yeah
right when you hit chapter 12 you'll
know the game takes a turn yeah and
uh you're either with it or you're not
with it yeah yeah well
i was all with it it was it was lit no
doubt shout out to flame
oh lords of gaming.net messi own flame
good afternoon rome sad attic also are
in the bushes
but i and solve are in the bushes but i
know this show will be good regardless
and remember cog
it's all in good fun yes sir i know
what's about to happen you know i know
what's going on shout out to the blaze
bret bingham final super chat king and
attic will be like iron man and the hulk
iron man punching hope go to sleep go to
sleep go to sleep
get well added yo i forgot about that
part in the movie
i actually hated that you hated that
party yeah yeah cause you're unfair yes
i'm a huge hulk fan i remember
telling me that he can do anything to
him no doubt
shout out to big cloud gaming follow
super chat you already know you know the
drill
hit that like button salute to the laws
and the homies slow mo yo first one
shout out to big clown
yo 10 k brother thank you
brother yo bro congratulations
yeah i think yeah he had a nice little
interview yesterday uh
i think an employee of ign too yes shout
out
to him shout out to him man he's out
here doing it big and then it looks like
someone
what did he somebody outside the box
came in here
are we allowing people outside the box
in the realm
it's just random people man in your
podcast you need better security
all right we're going to get to the
security king that's deebo
is here there'll be no tattoos today
[Laughter]
he gotta go send your grandson and you
get out of here
what's going on will be what's happening
gentlemen serious guys you gotta
be back i appreciate it man glad for
holding us down appreciate you getting
behind the box to crew
everybody's doing all right oh yeah
no complaints at all and this time i
actually don't have kobe while i'm in
the realm that's awesome oh man god
god bless god bless a lesson it's really
serious out here exactly let me get the
rest of the super chat smitty smith
shout out to play nyc rush down revolt
shoulders of giants squish and iop for
grinding for the people salute
the book of that squish yeah
that it really put the foam on me man
it's a lot more you go there's a game
that's for you
that is literally like the back
scratcher game 2.0
of the way they presented it yeah
gene know what it is we're gonna get to
that but um let me get that and then
we'll almost finish up with dan lazzaro
turned on some chat
yeah yeah was a talking sibling wow
come on dad don't do it please at least
at least they had to
wait for ssd to get lip sync i'm done
you're out of control oh my god
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito spread
that roman real estate robin iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to the
last word we had a boxes ty god travis
little thursday early edition
you know what i'm saying talk about
what's going on with the pvp sandbox all
the craziness with bungie please check
that out
that is up there now we might actually
go to thursdays we're thinking about it
we like last one on thursday so check
that out obviously i've been playing
back for blood
a little bit of destiny a little bit of
mlb to show so you know that's what's
been
it for me probably all your mets doing
ah
you had to do that welcome welcome you
had do you have to do that right
you've been quiet
[Laughter]
we're not gonna talk about that i'm not
trying to be better funky down here
shout out to buyers and the crew
hopefully they get it together and stop
making me stress out
but anyway let's get this poll question
popping off last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken
to the question with the recent release
and initial positive reception of the
halo infinite
multiplayer tech preview do you think
343 could survive
a mediocre campaign component to the
game
the winner at 70 percent of the vote was
no halo infinite campaign campaign must
be better
than halo 5 and impactful for the master
chief storytelling group
coming in at second at 21 of the vote
was yes
halo multiplayer and additional modes
will still add longevity to the game
and in last place with only seven
percent of the vote was the messy lords
i don't care but if these story leaks
keep happening it don't matter how hot
the campaign
shout out to the lords in the room i'm
actually gonna bring this over to will
me will me how important do you
think halo's campaign is to infinite do
you agree with the people
to me i don't care about the campaign as
much as i do to multiplayer because
that's what i'm gonna play most oh
you're the 21
wow i'm definitely 21 because honestly
and i've said it before i haven't really
played halo since three
okay but the uh the flight last week i
put 25 hours into that flight over the
weekend
yeah flight was good the flight was
solid the flight will have been flying
oh i enjoyed it
now i'm gonna assume slow-mo is on the
opposite side but i'm asking slow-mo do
you agree with the people where are you
at with it
well i don't think so like let's say if
the campaign is mediocre let's say it's
not
it's not as good it's closer to the side
of halo guardians campaign
than say what people want i don't think
it means 343 is done
or the game itself is done i think
they've already kind of like
thought of contingencies in that regard
i think
uh joseph staton being in the position
that he's in
was uh already kind of kind of strategic
yeah i think that if uh if this doesn't
go well
initially that they're going to continue
to
work on halo infinite the same way they
work on uh sea of thieves
yeah like it's always going to continue
to be an ongoing game that has ongoing
content
but you may see say bonnie no longer
being there you may see some of the
other
structural changes yeah clearly there
needs to be a change in culture in order
for
the game to reach the same uh quality
the same heights that the previous uh
bungie
halo games had and so in order to do
that you're going to have to really
change the culture and what's going on
and i think that they have
necessarily already like pulled the
trigger on that but they kind of got
some things in place just in case that
does happen
so i i i'm on the side of the campaign's
gotta be good
yeah but if it isn't it doesn't mean
three four three stop
no doubt no doubt before we start
actually um last week i want to send an
apology to the realm um
there's been a lot of merch going up and
uh gotta
do the shout outs that uh i miss so
really quickly before we get into the
first topic
i gotta shout out dave c who brought
that zip hoodie he said i gotta shout
out the best podcast out there y'all
blessed us with a proper zip hoodie
and to make it even more more of a
no-brainer
have a good podcast gentlemen don't
salute them thank you for that zip
you know what i'm saying and also
anonymous gotta say your name you gotta
see you cop the zip hoodie the zip hold
these is moving they got the iop
it's getting colder yeah it's getting
cold you know what i'm saying i see the
one with the um
iop logo shout out to oh shout out to
butch
shut up without the push that was
hilarious we are not doing that is
69 you got the classic t in green proud
to be a member of the realm can't
wait to rep it at last damn media live
salute you salute to lsu absolutely
defining duke i will see you guys there
in p.a and then shout out to again
someone to say the name but he said he
bought
he got the great pull over he uh hoodie
he said king
he said shout out to king take those
knees with that ssd
relax baby okay because you know what it
is he knows what's going on
oh man i found out some information on
that ssd
oh boy i think i know where this is
going we've we've been lied to
bamboozle some of us have been
hoodwinked i'm
done all right anyway
but we got that out the way yes
thank you thank you will me for bringing
order here i need some order here but
yeah i guess
i'm i'm waiting i'm waiting for king to
add and run them up yeah yeah
we already know who's been running
people is
okay but anyway we got to get to it man
so first topic
up got lord gene in the brown i want him
to set it off first man playing why i
see it just want to do a real
brief recap for those that you know
unfamiliar with the convention obviously
me you shout out to the team
shout out to me you hai shout out to kai
batsu pulling up you know i'm saying
obviously
toughest situation this year you know
you know we got colvid we had the
regulations and stuff like that we had
adhered to of course
with the unfortunate you know delta you
look like a real ninja when you say
oh what i did yeah
yes i had to ditch it up you know these
so yeah shout out to the obviously we
know what the in new york city with the
called the delta variant there's been an
extra added restriction of the mask
indoor which we had to adapt to
the last minute but all that being said
we were in the building so uh
lord gene what was your recap your
impressions
any standouts for you player or c your
floor is yourself
uh so mostly what was there was a lot of
really really early development indie
games of the smaller teams looking for
funding
especially in the northeast i didn't
really meet anyone that was
international normally when we go to
these events there's a lot more yeah
there's no international but good point
uh what stood out for me
was we'll start with uh avalanche i
guess right yeah
and i didn't know that they had a
hunting simulation in game pass they
have a game called
uh the hunter in game pass so i want to
check that out
hunting simulation game supposed to be
one of the best
in the market for that um second
extinction i never got a chance to play
that just we were so busy
i don't play anything in early access i
actually played at the show floor and i
really enjoyed that that's in game pass
i guess they're helping
develop that or publish that or whatever
it is they're doing and of course
we begged them about contraband
we tried to strong-arm them they yo they
had their media training
they microsoft wasn't here like that let
loose
[Laughter]
i didn't expect that i didn't expect
them to be a loose lit with that because
that that game was super early in
development and stuff like that and they
still flashing stuff
and along with the rumors of that
acquisition and they didn't they didn't
say anything
really meaningful at all but it's and
it's not just
who i i won't even i don't want to say
yeah this person said this at the play
nyc event because i can't remember
if they did or not but when you ask
someone if they're if they've been
acquired by microsoft and their answer
is we can't talk about that
it really
the first way you can tell if somebody's
been acquired is you look at the shoes
oh my lord you look at these shoes if
they're wearing
new shoes these are the gucci these are
the gucci ankles that we were talking
about the gucci
we step your foot game up very bad
so you get that microsoft money you're
going to get those bruno magleys or
something like that
so we went from robin hood and tights to
forrest gump all right yes all right
i'm just saying you know you get those
gucci flip-flops you get those weak
ankles stuff happens
when you get that cash yeah
[Laughter]
there we go got him
we did find out a cool little detail
that microsoft gave them the licensing
for the original
1975 microsoft logo to use the
contraband trailer
to set that tone which we thought was
really cool uh so they're they're very
tight with microsoft marketing over
there
uh so that was avalanche and um
you worked very hard gene any other
any other there was one particular
standout feature pretty good
we have a developer interview up on the
website just go towards gaming.net and
it's going to be right there
all of our twitter feeds it's right here
got that yeah
let me tell you let me give you let me
let me let me tell you something now
this is a moment where i get to
you know flex do you think you
dudes only talk about stuff that you
hear about
excuse me hello excuse me hello i heard
you're making a game
excuse me hello logicalgaming.net we're
here
so shout out to lords of gaming.net
actually reviewing games finishing them
oh
actually out here any streets risking
their life we're cold with two of our
guys
down right now but we out here flexing
this i don't know i would have been
there if i
would have gotten my modern shot if i
got it you're good you're good you're
good
we are the streets go there and watch
that video and you're going to see
real journalism because real journalism
is almond oh i'm going to get that work
for work
it's a little to the table you don't you
don't get an email can i schedule and
talk to you
yo why you gotta do that there goes your
chances of being with ig yeah we're
messy now he he best you messing with me
he went left he went left no you know
what we take all of y'all
no doubt no hey let's hear it listen
it's all good man
love the team like i said a tremendous
article competitors yeah we
outside you know kick is messy but we
all saw it it was fun
and could continue no king be a mess and
continue
so uh fullness of giants from a small
team in brooklyn
i would like to see a microsoft or a
devolver or someone come up and give
them some cash because i think they
could use another year or two
imagine hades third person
but it's the robot from big hero 6
being ridden by slippy from starbucks
like you just imagine slippy with a gun
their hand i don't know just look at
gender on top of big hero 6
shooting people and then the robots got
like a sword and everything it's just
the craziest coolest thing
and it's so much fun it's great i think
it's very far away from being finished
yeah uh but we do have a lot of gameplay
up we have a developer interview
and i'd i'd really like to see a bigger
company come by and give them some cash
to really make something special there
because it's like a fun third-person
hades yes okay i gotta get up to g
because you're fired king
would love this game because all right
it's all right so picture
this little frog right he got the toast
right
and he on this big robot and the cool
thing about the robot is like
they work independently like you could
play it co-op where one person
controlled a robot and he's
it's like a big mac like a frog and a
mech with toast
and then the graphics is really good
like that no i was watching
yeah grass is really like you can see
they got it and i agree with g
like they if they could make because gee
down here trying to blow the budget
slo-mo he out here telling he said this
what y'all need to do
i need to go hire this voice actor and
then let it be like the mascot
and i need to curse he wanted like his
conqueror he wanted
the frog to have slick talk yeah
so you know he being a recruiter yeah
yeah he he out here with the dev
it was so funny but you could tell in
the early stages they
got something they just got to get like
somebody got to get behind him because
it does have a lot
of this is an unreal engine 4 game
is it i'm going to say if that was
exclusive third person effective and
then listening to
like the gameplay or like what the the
uh the elements of the game is and i can
kind of see how smaller devs have been
getting on unreal engine
before because it costs you nothing to
use the engine when you're small
and then also there's so many tools that
you can use the finish that makes it
the thing with that slo-mo on on these
shows
you're gonna see unity is more yeah it
seems like you need to be probably with
these guys
i was going to say that next yeah either
yeah the original
either unreal engine or unity those
always seem to be like
the two engines of choice 99 sure it was
unity yeah okay good good and what stood
out to me was like everything we played
there
was usually something created by an
artist and then the gameplay mechanics
were like conceptual
they asked the game tell them what the
game is game of thrones
shoulders of giants yeah it's on the
website right now you're gonna see that
no place else
ever wanna use that footage you gotta
solve something
no but uh of all the games we played
there the combat was uh unbelievably
smooth and polished like the combat is
ready to go
i i think it just because you could use
some good voice acting
um you know make the character a little
fun and then expand out what they're
doing with the enemies and expand out
what they're doing with the levels
you know so i'd love to see a publisher
come in and and scoop this game up yes
really
now gene when you said this third person
perspective it's that
camera over the shoulder perspective or
is it a little bit more
like isometric or like where exactly is
the camera it sits
back on like a little bit further from
his back because they can sit center
view of the screen
uh yeah i was dissecting the hell out of
that game yeah i'm trying to picture it
right i'm trying to picture it oh you
don't really have to just try all you
could do is go to the game with that
game
all right
[Laughter]
i love it i love it but yeah that was
one that definitely in um yeah any other
ones before i go
gene i had you uh the last one i have is
a game called squish from pm studios
and that is like super early i'd like
again i'd like to see someone especially
like a devolver that did fall guys come
in and give them a little bit of money
and time to
to really refine things but it's like
super smash brothers played
under a tetris game but there's no
punching there's no kicking it's just
you just push each other
and the blocks come down and you get
squished underneath the box so you don't
yeah
yeah it was really fun definitely fun
and fun interview with the devs that was
full player co-op right yeah four-player
co-op
yeah squish they were great great team
they got they definitely got a lot of
and they actually uh pm studios i
believe it's it's a team and then
they've actually been responsible for a
lot of very cool other games that i
didn't even know they were social a lot
of bigger name titles
so it's cool to see them out there that
was really cool um i'll jump in real
quick i want to give a shout out
to my man lord tune medic one of the
coolest stories king like
so we're getting like we're on the media
line waiting to get in
and then like you know how someone hit
you with the look you don't say it like
like they know you and i'm just like all
right you know obviously the shirts
everything you know what i'm saying
people pulling up off the shirts
salute the king with the marketing you
know
from listening to iron law podcast i was
so inspired to support
gaming in new york city i decided to
volunteer at the play nyc event
and i was lucky enough to get selected
for the opportunity so he was now a
volunteer
because he listened to iop and i was
like yo that's
crazy so we did the joy you know i'm
saying it was a couple of people like
that that we pulled up on but um
yeah man the show was was phenomenal we
had that obviously are we talking first
question question go forward
question what where did you eat for
lunch no we had to bounce we didn't
normally we did the treat
gene held the tradition he was like yo
we're going to do the joint jean was
down to do it it's just gene
is shaking his head is upset messed up
gene
yeah you guys still hungry i'm still
okay all right
okay we're all right so
you all right you told them they were
supposed to go get the pizza right
oh no i just googled mapped korean
barbecue because like we were in the
center of manhattan it's like guys
with some free and barbecue they wasn't
in the same place cog
okay so first of all guys let me tell
you something if you have play with nyc
right now if you did right now lemon
get yourself after you eat around the
corner where the old limelight used to
be yeah two blocks away
the the old studio 54 the oh yeah
the old drink it's it's right there
built
inside the old church on the side that
is the best
pizza in music it's really good the best
brick oven pizza real brick oven pizza
they bring it out
and make it to your specifications
mm-hmm let me tell you something
congress derek look dude oh my god i'll
take you all there
this would have never happened yes this
is where this is where the head of
marketing was supposed to be there
marketing and business from iop when it
would have handled that
but i had other responses
had some situation going on so he had to
leave so i was like all right
you know what we ain't gonna do it this
time but we will avenge
that let's get that jesus still saying
the coverage just yeah look at gene is
shaking his head because he's this is
this is not acceptable because this is
he knows gene knows how we get down like
he knows we're going we're going to play
hard we're going to eat hard
and we're going we going game hard facts
right pause so
he knows he's ready to play now now now
is the time to eat
you're like what are we doing korean bop
me and you went to the korean barbie
oh my god i would have had some kimchi
wrapped up in superman
you had a good job anyway being that
i've been called out during the
pregnancy
but the energy was good um again shout
out to lord dan butch go he was on his
one too he was out there on the floor
doing this thing ran into a bunch of
people i'm going to give a shout out
like i said avalanche
we tried to get some more information on
contraband y'all but they were they were
a little tight lit but we got some stuff
up on laundry gaming.net right now about
them and what they're working on
so go check that out i want to shout out
lady j
um from coexist gaming really positive
movement
she's actually a grammy nominated artist
who's actually doing this from the
hometown from brooklyn
really cool tournaments gaming stuff our
energy was amazing
yeah yeah bk stand up it was lit check
that out um we talked about some
shoulders of giants obviously we talked
about them it uh
rogue light frog robot combo really cool
you know
oh i wanna shout out uh rush down revolt
i believe vortex games
that was a hardcore fighter that'll beat
that's actually up right now on lords of
gaming.net
check that out my interview with the dev
so it's like no place else right yeah
you ain't getting that that's okay shout
out to lords again
so um yeah that one if you're a smash
brothers guy but this is like
hardcore smash bros fgc
parries cancels that hardcore tekken
vibe but weight smash
four play it was really good um shout
out to jonah from welford games um kung
fu kickball was back
fire fire he's close yeah he's close it
was lit
we'll have that up later he so he's he's
in the same stage as swim sanity dudes
yeah so sadly dudes i'm gonna tell you
that dave was there decoy was there
shout out to decoy in the building um
they are working on a new game
oh decoys working on new they learned a
lot from me last joint shout out to them
it's just now the two brothers now not
the third don't work with three it's
just two
and then um yeah they had they was out
they were doing it yeah the two brothers
is uh the actual uh the gameplay stuff
but now
but now decoys are just officially two
moving forward so they straighten it out
because i did ask that question whatever
so they straight that out
and then they had the tournaments and
all that stuff going on but they are
working on a new game
they they cannot wait to talk about that
so we going to build with them on that
and then um last one remember um pax
east um we went to play craft in boston
remember when we had the drinks but we
had macho with us
and we took hot macho in the bar
and remember the devs had the ball
inside the restaurant
and it was the dude with the it was like
a gyroscope game but you jump on the
thing yeah
that was like he was back he had his
cousin
yeah running it right there yeah did the
interview because yeah that's
absolutely amazing was back he updated
the game
andrew thomas and andrew simon thomas
and he's got a new game it's called um
chile or something like that it looked
interested as like a watcher
it's hilarious he had that and the last
one it's not
up yet but it's the funniest was shot to
kaibab so he made me do this
right it's called the game is called
botsu right
and they gotta do first of all i was
like why is that dude running around
dressed up like a chicken
running around in him and it was crazy
so it was wait it was an actual dude
yeah in the venue full chicken outfit
right then they got a chick and a full
kimono outfit
and then announced it so remember the
gong show yeah
all right so it's the gong show but it's
like literally they they
do this in theaters right so apparently
they made a game and then they got a
board game and a regular game
so yo it is the funniest interview i've
ever done it is so much chaos going
around me while i'm interviewing
y'all gonna it is the funniest thing
i've ever i'm not gonna front i'm glad i
did it
because at first i was rolling my eyes i
was like what is this
[Laughter]
i was like what are they getting me into
but anyway it was lit that will be i'm
gonna try to get back to up uh tonight
and by the latest tomorrow one but yeah
it was lit
but shout out to them to the community
man it was good but new york shout out
to my boy
bone slave bonus slave in the building
you already know just a little bit of
curse how about that
yeah oh shout out to macho in the chat
he said that pizza at the bar was
slamming no doubt you already
know yeah but it was good that's when i
threw macho into the fire though yeah
you doing very first in the view
my thought he's gonna have a night of
good relaxation and schmoozing
no time to work exactly
but look that's what i got play nyc
against state keep it locked on lords of
gamer.net
tons of content coming up there y'all
got to get where we can get that again
launch the gaming.net you know what i'm
going to say
check it out there's only people that
got it though exactly that's the only
people
salute to them but yeah the indie scene
is alive and well
and for them to come out the way they
did in a pandemic
and just the energy of the city was
really really good shout out to you
looking like a real ninja woo thank you
thank you so much
i had to keep my monika where it was but
yeah salute the one away he's out there
right now he's doing his thing he's on
his one-two
hip-hop a couple other people new york
was right stand up you already know
honey guys eclipse you already know what
it is so anyway we got to get to it so
another game kind of came out this week
um
back for blood open beta impressions
you know what i'm saying i want to shout
out somebody first addict's not here but
he knows what i'm talking about my man
coolge cast big big fan of you doing the
lord's work for the community
on these open beta codes salute to you
brother cause woo
you that helped a lot of people but uh
yeah i had to salute him man he's a good
dude and uh yeah we gotta talk about it
so back to blood is out
impression so i want to start probably
with slo-mo wilmy just um
if you guys have played it i think
someone i think you did play it because
i remember seeing
a twitch stream and i definitely want to
get will because i know he is the horror
fan so let's start with you slow mo um
what what are your thoughts so far on it
you know if you uh and how long have you
played it
i've probably played about five hours of
it so far
okay i'm a big left 4 dead fan like me
and my homies like we when we first
played left 4 dead back in the day
it was just like this this was the game
this was our
game like we weren't playing halo we
were playing left 4 dead
actually one of my best one of my best
friends still plays that game with his
family with his wife and his kids he
still plays
he plays left 4 dead too so good on pc
which is like they've
actually taken some of the the original
left for that maps put them in left 4
dead 2 so it was all together
so like i was all ready for this uh and
i'm i'm actually really impressed with
what we have here so essentially it's
left for dead
but with better visuals and better guns
yeah better gun play i love the guns
way better gun play and but it's still
left for dead
where for people who aren't familiar
with left 4 dead essentially like
there is no i'mma go solo oh
that guy that guy ends up dead every
single time because
you're gonna get hit with a special
zombie that's going to yoke you up
drag you somewhere you're going to get
hit with some huge
muscle-bound incredible hulk zombie
that's just going to pop out of nowhere
and punch you across the mat
you're going to run out of ammo and be
looking like boo boo the fool out there
it's going to happen you have to if your
teammate is hurt
and he's like about to die you have to
give him your med kit
yes or heal him yourself yes you have to
be able to
keep the team together because you can't
win on your own and this that kind of
co-op
they learned they got gameplay from
evolve yes they did they clearly it's
like
if you're thinking like oh no i i heard
about evolve or i played the vault i
didn't like it this is nothing like that
this is
left out nothing yeah yeah and it is i
love it
it's it's pretty awesome i played it
with yash and lucas
uh played it with david gaines shout out
to him and and the sly crow
uh it was we didn't we made it probably
about to the third area you know how
like you'll go through an area get to a
safe house
and then you can kind of restock try to
make it to the next safehouse we made it
like past two safe houses before we
started to just get bodied
and there's friendly fire yes but you
can kind of like
their their difficulties you can go
straight you know noob
and just like no friendly fire right you
could do the second level well but just
like 35 percent
friendly fire damage so if you shoot
your your your buddy it's only
going to give you 35 damage clearly
that's still enough
yeah um or just full on 100 percent
friendly fire
we were at 35 percent what i like is oh
like the the i call it the left for dead
isms the nuances like with the friendly
fire
it's like stop shooting me come on watch
the [ __ ] like they get mad like the
voice acting when you mess up like
the voice actors getting mad as well as
your own buddies are getting mad yeah
just like
who's still shooting me stop running in
my fire lane like it's just like
i mean i felt like he was sniping us
more than the zombies i i would have
like 80 percent health
bow wait a minute 20 what happened to me
i brought it back my bad man i'm like
come on
bro yeah like you just know like there
was
one part we had like we had the
activator crane the kind of
and we had no ammo but we all down to
our melee well
you can run out of ammo yeah that quick
yeah yeah yeah it's very different from
original left 4 dead when it comes to
ammo where in the original left
dead there was just ammo piles for
everyone so if you
it may even matter what kind of weapon
you had you would go to the ammo pile
you can restock your ammo it was fine
they made it more difficult now
where it's only in the individualized
ammo for certain weapons so
if you have an smg but then you see some
ammo on the ground you run to it oh
sorry that's sniper ammo yeah yeah
yeah very specific ammo good point yeah
so you actually have to plan it out with
your teammates like who's going to use
what weapon
because if you're all using assault
rifle yeah you're going to be knowing
you're going to run that ammo
no one's going to have anything it
almost encourages the different
for for players to take different
weapons i would agree
that's that's a huge change that's a
huge change left for dead the original
games because uh
usually everybody get assault rifle or
something like that
and and um the ammo was like does the
ammo crate everybody
get ammo um so you're telling me that
there's a strategic element to
actually planning out to go out and
that's that's pretty decent yeah
yeah yeah definitely so i'm enjoying it
i didn't do the pvp
i've only done the campaign stuff that i
really would like
indulge in for the most part but this is
a game that i i planned on buying day
one anyway even before it got
became a launch game and game pass so
you you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
have it installed on my xbox series
uh you know uh game pass pc is a bit
iffy
yeah i'm gonna try it on yeah i know
they gotta work on that i don't know i
saw your art i saw your tweet
yeah but if if it's performing like it
usually does
which is like what the heck is going on
right now i might just go go
cop it on steam so we'll see what
happens let me get will me in because uh
wilmy is the lord
of horror so i'm glad he was able to
show up today i definitely want his
perspective and also
will me correct me if i'm wrong um i
think i was looking at your timeline
besides the
amazing memes that you have
besides i mean you you i think you were
like me where you
tested in a stream you guys tested cross
play
because the game does we did right so
tell me about your experience just in
general how you liking it how are you
feeling about
back for blood man i was blown away with
it
actually and what i did i wanted the
code for the ps5
okay so i played on ps5 husk and leo
played on pc and of course ghost play on
his series x knife
cross play worked flawlessly yeah
and the best part is too because in the
beginning i was like well i guess
we'll all have to jump on xbox live you
know go into a party chat but we didn't
have to do that yep
luckily with the party we were all able
to get in chat we could hear each other
just fine we even streamed the game
friday night
wow just to show everybody how well it
did work yeah
we had no issues with it yes and we went
through
i've completed the the campaign to give
you twice
nice nice we went through it twice
i know the part where slovo was
referring to about the crane and that is
not an easy part yeah and i learned very
well you never
never let husk behind you with any type
of power
what was i doing and see the bad part is
too you were talking about the
characters get mad
when you're ex-military and you're
playing with a bunch of guys that aren't
ex-military
we get even madder by the way
exactly you're like look you stay here
you stay over here
yep me here yes and you know i kept
picking on the guys i'm like look man
come on dude just stay out of the way
will take your teammate down with one
headshot oh yeah
oh yeah wow okay but there are so many
improvements in the game
compared to the last one and like
slow-mo said you know ammo
isn't that easy to find not at
all it's not like the originals yeah and
the zombies are more diverse
yes and these things will flood you
without you realizing it and they will
flank you from all sides
i gotta ask you a question because the
king might appreciate it dude yo
tell me the point like they'll throw
those cards uh i call them like they're
they're negative modifiers for some of
them right yeah
and there's one where it is these birds
and it's like
it's tempting to mess with the birds
right but if you
mess with it's worse than hitchcock bro
because they get that besides them
getting loose
they'll get swarms all over you like
they'll send
more matter of fact at the beginning of
the game there's an area where you're
going over top of these 18 wheelers yeah
and there's birds everywhere
i'm the one that kept shooting the birds
hey what's you know what's so funny king
it'd be like if the game will snitch
it'd be like will me alerted
first of all yeah cause you know how you
play those games and they'll be like yo
bro i didn't do anything bro i didn't
it wasn't me bro no will be did and the
game was
it's elaborate it tails on you every
time yeah
and i just laugh and go you shouldn't
know what i was going to do anyway
but yeah there's there's a few areas in
there man if you don't stick together
and get your stuff straight
you're not going to survive it like the
boat where you go to the ferry yes
the first time we tried to go through
there we got wasted
all four of us i mean they just put us
down quick
but the second time we went in with a
plan okay what'd you do
you know we're like we're to get the
explosives you go here you go here we're
going to coordinate this and we were out
of there
just a couple of minutes but that's the
catch
this game will take you by surprise
there
definitely has to be some coordination
between every player on your team
yeah so if not let me ask you a question
since you know since i'm a left a dead
freaking nut
all right dude do you have those those
places where you have to
all right like hit a mechanical
structure and then the horde or whatever
a drawbridge like in the very early days
yeah
yeah oh yeah and the crane the crane
that me and wilmie was talking about
that's one of those areas as well where
you you can't just rush through it
because like you know a veteran left for
their player would just like i know the
map
right i'm not going to move in slowly
because that's increasing the amount of
chances that a horde will overwhelm us
right you run through areas and you
hopefully don't set off any alarms or
car alarms matter of fact that one area
with a crane too
if you talk about the birds once you get
that crane
lifted you have to go down the street
with all these zombies coming out from
all sides and there's
birds all in the street and i'm sitting
by going look we're standing here by the
house let's just go ahead and shoot the
birds and get this over here
and then get it on fully let's just go
ahead and get it over with that way when
we get the rain
we got a clear shot there's so many and
then what i realized is like because of
the animal economy
like it's not really advertised just to
be so gung-ho
i don't know
i don't know do you think they might
change that from the beta like
a little bit more uh um available okay
um were y'all guys able to finish the
board
oh yeah yeah yeah okay yeah we went
through it twice
you know i'm i don't do betas yeah and
you would expect me to really do this
better
no no i know you always you consistently
you do that it's just all about
it's all about paying yeah you want
yours
yeah yeah you know why because i'm
hearing all this wonderful great stuff
that you guys did
you're going to love it i know i know i
know i am i
i also would love it actually if they
pay people
um i would love it more i respect you
at the same time um listen will me knows
as a business owner
everything received is earned you
understand oh yeah
you know hard work is paid and and they
used to have beta testers back in the
days it was a job that you applied for
right you go in there you apply for it
you sit down you play the game you get a
check
yay you helped them they helped you and
you left
right now since the event of the
internet they say yo how can we use
their fandom against them
how can we use this consumer to give me
all right so you gave me your money and
i'm gonna reward you with making you do
free labor
like that's not cool like you're not
wrong
i'm wrong he's not wrong after it
fill out the survey yeah
matter of fact i was participating in
another beta which i'm not even allowed
to say the name of
on social media i already know what game
you talking about
[Applause]
i waited for 35 minutes to connect to
this so-called
data my computer screen just sat
and it just spun and i'm like you know
what i'm done
i clicked on i can't say the name and
slow-mo i know you know what it what it
is
i just deleted the beta and walked away
i'll fail you
you did yourself a favor because
actually playing it was even worse than
waiting oh my god oh real
this is what i'm saying here this is the
only crust that that you know
that that sticks into me because
i see my brother in and i call you all
the better boys
they'll get your free t-shirts
i don't like that
my boy chris was playing it right some
um
had the headphones and he is so your
king
you're gonna love this and i said all
right cool
what are you getting well i i get a
chance to play it
they're capitalizing on your fomo right
i said i said so you went out you
pre-ordered right he said hell yeah
i said well one i know it's coming in
game pass so phil dominance maximus
really is spencer told me
hold your money sir partake
right so i said cool so then they tell
you all right so this is what this is
how to get you guys which is absolutely
nice
they said this weekend is for these
dudes that pre-ordered it
they're swarming in like
they they are taking advantage of the
fandom there's no doubt
there's no doubt but then in like a week
or two
everybody else for everybody to do it
again
of course marketing 101 that the
beautiful thing
yeah is beautiful but okay i'm just
telling
people and i know it's not it's going to
fall upon you yeah because we i'm not
listening we're continuing humans like
music you like to be used to that listen
well that's what i like about doing it
i try to tempt you and you you hold firm
because you know why i honestly believe
that i'm not going to allow them to take
advantage of
me and you know um they have done it
microsoft
constantly does this with that alpha
program crap that they got in the
background
see all right here's the real story now
let me let me tell will be a slow though
real engine
really see what this is is at one point
slo
king was uh inside he
[Laughter]
he was a lead member of the group like
the backstreet boys
he's a former beta boy right so what
happened is
it will be dave remember the insider
program they put you in that alpha ring
right
now right in the fine print it says you
will have instabilities
you know we're warning you if you're
going to get all these new features
first
so i never forget he had i forgot it was
like a call of duty car it was a
specific console he had it
was my call of duty console
the one where you press the button to
make the sounds oh that's my favorite
one that's my favorite i do get i do
give microsoft credit they did replace
it
i've actually replicated xboxes yes sort
of alpha programming yeah
alphabet i don't have a problem doing
betas for games but
being in those alpha programs on my con
i that's what i draw the line
and that's where king drew the line yeah
i'm not going to have that because he's
not going to tell you the full story
so i was doing raids every day
all day damn near 24 hours a day
i had my gala horn we was in there
taking down crota we was doing it up
so i ran in and it's time for us i get
back from work and i'm running my house
and i'm
my beta boys shirt
[Laughter]
you know cause you gotta do that that's
the baby boy
so i turned my console on
yes me would not launch bro
i wanted to throw myself out the window
i said what the hell is going on what's
happening
and then there's a reddit post that said
if you an alpha program
this is what's happening and they don't
know how to stop it
we don't know how to smile so i try to
delete it i
[Laughter]
i had to run out and buy a new concept
i'm running out the gate stop
i got the new i got the halo one
halo i said take this this thing
does not play destiny
[Laughter]
it was so messed up i know king went so
low and left debatable he left the beta
boys
from that moment on i was singing cry me
a river yeah he
he so he's the jt to our beta boys he's
just the typical man
split up it was a bad split but yeah man
look
absolutely i want to get gina before we
get you i want to get off super chat
real quick shout out to uh michael aka
bed stop find his file switch out
shout out to gene for having both marvel
versus capcom games
in the background love the dreamcast
love sir and yes god bless say less
so gene about that marvel cop and uh did
you get a chance to be
part of the beta boys were you rocking i
i
i am a beta boy we're getting jackets
made next week we gotta get these
club to get jackets made um i got a code
from wb and i got a code from
david on lords of gaming.net who hooked
me up
um but uh king i've got a question for
you
yes sir i i did the early pre-order
access for the division and i did the
early pre-order access for anthem
and and i all of the issues i reported
on the division ubisoft fixed in time
for launch
all of the issues i reported on anthem
were still there when the game came out
like
you know 60 days later whatever it was
with all the problems and bugs and
things that i think about
about uh back for blood should i do you
think i should
waste my sunday reporting that in to
make it a better game for everyone or
you think i should just
shut up and just go do what i got to
you know um that whole uh beta testing
thing they probably do small beta
testing inside within employees but
they need a stress test for the actual
game and stuff like that so this is
where you guys come in
if you already agreed to that aspect of
it and you see a bug or whatever
you know report the bug because
hopefully they do fix it
um i i really i mean i say it in jess
but i can never tell anybody how the
game why the game and where they should
game right
so you know you do your best and it's
really because of you guys that are
actually out here beta testing these
games that we do
get the better release when it does come
out they actually
better boy emoji i said
we can get it we need more members oh
shout out to paris
he says tcl for life king yo uh paris
paris
stop that i'm not acknowledging that
and i won't and because i got love for
you there will be no slander
now wait a minute wasn't there wasn't
there a band back in like the 80s that
had a song similar it was called a
personality what yeah
what's the name of that song and now it
keeps running through my eyes oh man i
think i know what you're talking about
oh my god but continue continue y'all
good to see you so so
i just i just feel that yeah yeah please
do that if if that's in your warehouse
if that's something that you don't want
to do then don't yeah but
again i feel free labor
is not cool they should give you
something they should give you a skin
in the game that did participate in the
beta yo here's this give a free scarf on
your neck so
when you see the next beta boy you'll be
like you dude
i know you clown in the beta boys but in
defense
most of the games do give you like that
skin
or like hey you were there even pump g
beta boy y'all had to had the jackets
we were out here they had come on this
is where my
for myself come in this is it because i
baited tested
that chicken dinner craze
especially when you get your first
chicken dinner and the floor ain't there
hey
he's giving me an idea though because i
think i've got a bunch of applications i
gotta look through i gotta hire some
people
okay i'm just gonna i'm just gonna pull
them in my office i'm going to beta test
them
that way i don't legally have to pay
them listen here you go we're going to
bring you to the job site we're going to
bait it how could you say
that to the letter of the law king is
right in the fact that
you know these gay companies aren't
capitalizing off our four but i want to
finish with g gene's experience this
whole thing
but i do find it incredibly interesting
to see how a game changes from from beta
to launch in terms of you know what gets
fixed and what doesn't get fixed
yeah um and so some things i ran into
you guys are right about the gun play
the gun play and back for blood is
phenomenal
um because of the working on the site
all weekend because of playing yc i've
been playing back for bloated some weird
hours
uh like seven o'clock this morning i've
got about five hours in
uh this weekend um the i so i play
i usually play with one or two people
randomly in quick play
and then i get bots and the bots are
awful
the bots it's cool that they can shoot
through every single asset in the game
and they just like find the zombies
wherever they are on the map and like
auto lock
on like you know like when you're
watching a multiplayer shooter and like
a streamer's cheating
and they can just like the bullet just
finds the person that is happening a lot
for me i'm seeing that which is cool
because they're bots right they're not
helping me in any way but
i'll be like pointing a bot to like the
the medic thing like there's no zombies
around go get go
right here charge up and it's just
sitting there with like one health bar
left it's like oh god i'll give you my
bandages
and then um if i'm dead the bots are not
gonna do anything to help and
sometimes the bots are doing stuff where
i have to actually check and see if it's
like
someone in the game goofing around and
invested you know just being a troll
or a bot is like stuck doing something
crazy the bots are completely useless
um i heard that i heard that um from my
boy chris
that he had he had a video up with the
bot was just shooting the floor
yeah i was just about to say that that
happened to me i got swarmed i'm
down shooting my pistol the bot
is like three feet away from me shooting
at the wall
yo speaking of where slow mo's best he
got a funny tweet right now
come on you better continue
uh i think the people who have that itch
for left 4 dead are going to be very
happy
i think people who don't or never played
it uh this is a game deeply rooted in
2008 this is like a homage to left 4
dead
um it's it's that with
loot boxes and this card system tacked
on
yes that we don't know how the
monetization works yet
good point good so i'm glad that's in
game pass
yes and you know so it is a game that
the level design
is built around 2008
and it is it looks a lot better than
left 4 dead because it's you know
13 years newer of course um and
i just don't think it looks that great
uh
and then the bots are terrible outside
of that
is bringing us back down yeah um
i uh just want to keep it real from
perspective
one of the best reviews let me ask you a
question gene
being at the game is launching inside
game pass and uh game pass is geared to
you know the you say the 28 million
people that they have there now
it's it's it's more skewed to
multiplayer because we've noticed that
with
games like the outriders which is a
multi-player uh centric game oh you're
gonna love
the whole question continue yeah and and
and we have like destiny and stuff like
that
we see that these multiplayer centric
games thrive in it do you think
that that aspect would eliminate those
issues that you're feeling like you have
with bots and stuff like that because
there will be
a good large player base for people to
join in and other people will be there
yeah i just think the con is that let's
say hypothetically and i don't believe
this is going to happen let's say
hypothetically halo launches in november
15th right that means that 30 days this
player base is gone
maybe i don't know that's that's a bit
extreme i don't mean entirely
it's not it's not the greatest game ever
made back for blood and
i think it is going to have a
problematic launch and
people are people are going to have play
the the the open beta next weekend and
they're going to see what i'm talking
about
that's a really bad experience with the
bots but if you do have a group of
friends together i feel like it's gonna
be a ton of fun
if you're upset with activision you play
zombies with your friends this is the
game
this is an amazing addition to game
passes the game i was gonna buy that i'm
not buying now it's a game pass
which i'm sure there's probably five or
ten other million people they're in the
same exact boat that i am
and and it'll be a game that throughout
the year next year that people can come
back to
but like that week that halo's out
you're not playing this game i got a
question
all right because because you did bring
up the halo factor and that's the
fear right the halo fair fact is you
know people are afraid of
other games uh large multiplayer games
that are being launched in that area
but i i i counted that with the last
um the left for dead one in left too
uh those games uh also had to contend
with
uh juggernauts which was call of duty
battlefield halo and stuff like that of
that like
but they found a niche and they got like
a core audience and such a following
through that the game even transcends
its normal packaging where you'll see
like a left 4 dead launched inside
what's that game that zombie games army
army trilogy
you get a package of the left for dead
people there you've seen other games
that actually
had the left for dead skins and stuff
like that so do you think that this game
will continue that lineage
that uh this like because we we know
that cult classics in a lot of things
and wilmy can attest to this
people like rob zombie has a ravage it
rabbit following to a point that
whatever he puts out
his core will always shore up for it do
you think that
core that is crying for this game will
actually support it through
the halo chaos that will be coming those
people
yeah those people are going to be very
happy and um
i think that this game will end up
somewhere in between evolve
and left for dead eventually and i think
without game pass
it is in the evolve category okay let me
let me you know go next i'm going to get
to super chat and then i'll jump in
shout out to stitch five super chat ads
or controller is broken but fun
snapping and shoot is an auto headshot
here right that saves me a lot of evil
i was using the desert eagle and the
vector no doubt shout out to smitty
smith with the five dollar super chat
looks like the beta boys coming out on
stage with the matching tcl socks
looking like chris hart
[Music]
i
so look man i would jump in real quick
um i pretty much agree with everybody um
my first experience with it was i want
you know obviously huge
i'm biased huge left for dead fit that
is clearly one of my favorite games on
the 360 era
i used to play that we used to play that
thing for hours it's absolutely
hilarious
you know what i'm saying so shout out to
that um the first thing i notice off the
back
engine update smooth what was impressive
to me
is going into the trading range of me
initially because
let's be real like i don't look for
left 4 dead games to have good gun play
that's just something i'm kind of
accustomed to
it not being solid and i have to admit
man like
i was messing around with the different
guns they have all the on the table you
know and stuff like that the second
shooting range shooting range was really
nice man pulling out the little
secondary
the little off shotgun there's a second
there you have the pistols you can have
your melee weapons but
the gun play felt really tight now i do
agree with stitch the ads is
crazy like like they they're making it
so you're going to get these headshots
so if you're not like super skilled with
a sniper this is the game to showcase
all your lack of skill because they
gonna help you with the ads so that's
that
but i gotta agree with will be another
thing that impressed me and this is the
thing
again i know cross play is the wave
right now right
but the problem i'm having with games
like chivalry which i love
outriders it and you you mean you could
have tested this slow like
the the the the the onboarding for cross
play in a lot of these games are
terrible
yeah and i love the way back for blood
does it it is so seamless because
um i think even destiny is going to
apply the strategies they use because
you have your you know your
gamer tag based on your pro your console
right so
whatever console you see your your xbox
friends
if you play xbox right but then there's
the back for
blood friends list right oh so you gotta
ask okay what's your back for blood name
you type it in instantly and then you
can keep that person as a friend and the
cool thing is when you're you're grouped
up in a party
which i like it'll be like will me it'll
say his console you know what i'm saying
with the icon it'll show him on
pc slow-mo with the icon pc this one
with the icon
xbox this i love that they even did the
playstation involved yes playstations
yeah and they you go like a king they
got a ping snitch
you can press start and you'll be like
who's ping is not it
yeah i like that
anyway like i said
so anyway but it was really seamless i'm
like
this is what i want from cross play you
know i mean and i remember that shout
out to
you you want to know what who's playing
on what yeah
it's more so like what annoys me i think
chivalry is the most fun romp with
friends right
we got to do that yeah but the problem
is like slow it flows on pc
right i can't even there's no way to
match into a lobby with him
right i gotta hope through matchmaking
through 65 players that we get
and there's no chance that we definitely
get on the same team
and that's what i like what back for
blood does but anyway to the gun play
like i said love it vintage left for
dead vibes
the voice actor even the character
models they're absolutely hilarious
all the different type of characters it
feels like the walking dead you know
the universe you don't say that whole
type of thing it it
what i like is like oh when we said i
love the friendly fire stuff you know
what i'm saying i love it it adds
extra dimension to extra realism you
can't just baffle yeah you can't just go
gung-ho they got all the different
things
you could just take your team out yeah
yeah
leave them as food for the zombies shout
out to cat daddy
him had a hilarious clip he trying to
open it i'm like bro you
the game is telling you you need a
specific type of um kit
to open this door nah i'm gonna get the
explosive weak let's see
and i'm like so he blew himself to a kid
yeah that sounds like something that
elder cat would do that is
the cat yeah shout out to elder cat
cause he's trying to improvise on his
own
out here messing around but it was
absolutely hilarious
again the gun play what i love is they
the weapons the nuances the attachments
you know you can find specific
attachments i was getting into my uzi
bag they had i could find scopes you
could fight so p
you you actually like work with your
team like yo i got an attachment for the
gun you got over here
hey yeah so that's the part i actually
like that strategy layer with the
weapons you know i'm saying
i'm gonna disagree with my lords of
gaming.net brother whether
that this game is gonna gonna die off
quick with halo you know i really think
they got it man i really think they got
one i think the issue is gonna come down
to to his point the servers yes they're
gonna have to be
you know small on launch when the mass
has come i agree with them there
you know that they have to have a
steward loss but i think it's
so much of a spiritual successor to left
for debt and such of the
the fields and everything is there you
know even without the quote-unquote pvp
mode that they they don't have right now
or they don't intend on having right now
this when you crank it up on a
difficulty is going to be a romp with
friends it's going to do it
it's hard it bro right bro it is going
to do well and the other thing about it
is
to king's point game pass that is huge
this is the perfect game for game pass
high five so
but remember you have to shoot light
bulbs in the game that's the newest
thing
you got you actually good but i think
this is going to be a problem
he does i know what he talked about but
at the end of the day
i'm leaving that i'm leaving that low
beta boy inside
no it's actually a twitter joke from
this morning it's a twitter joke
we went from bananas to light bulbs yes
oh my god we're gonna leave a little bit
at the end of the day look i think it
it's gonna be good but
again we'll see what happens with the
player base when the other other other
other
other
other
other
other
other other
other
other
other
other
other other other other other guys yeah you
gotta read this
oh man what's going on what's going on
so we got
oh man we were talking about chris have
you ever read g4 yeah
ray g4500 chris hart is the david ruffin
of the beta boys
ain't nobody coming to see you otis
working on the new single ssd confetti
wow
[Applause]
y'all lose today but anyway
look i thought it was a fun game we'll
see what happens but i get when it opens
up when gene for next week for the uh
for
the for the public yes next weekend okay
to gene's point
we gotta see how those servers do then
you know what i mean so
it is what it is so we gonna move on
unless you got anything else from back
for black y'all
all right bye for blood it is out if
you're in the early joint if not but we
are gonna move on
goes to sushiba legends looks like this
was addict's topic looks like there is a
new mode going on right now
and it's going to be mostly a standalone
release
and rivals pvp mode so yeah the upcoming
director's
cut icky island dlc won't be required so
this is a free 99 y'all you get up in
there
and um it says uh goshi shima's uh
multiplayer mode is getting a bunch of
new content in the weeks ahead starting
with the new two v
two pvp mode called rivals on september
third and then i believe to suck a punch
dev
he was talking about um again how would
be a free update
also gonna have um cross play and cross
progression between playstation 4 and
playstation 5.
so that's it so i don't know who are
legends fans i'll start
with jean and then i get to will me um
jean are you
alleged have you played legends at all
for goshi sushima
no i had a feeling this was a ps5
version was coming so i was gonna wait
for that to get into legends and i'll
give it a shot
wait a second wait a second if this is
only ps4
no no no it's it's ps4 and ps4 legends
is a multiplayer component that came out
uh yes
last year this year for missus but i was
waiting for the ps5 version because i
don't want to go back and forth and keep
playing it just want to play something
finish it and then
go to the next game okay i'm a little
confused yes
i'm just confused i just need a little
bit of clarity clarity
all right so yeah when they're releasing
it they're releasing
only the playstation 4 version first and
then the playstation 5 version or
they release both of them at the same
time at the same time it's going to
launch at uh september 3rd the
the oh okay so so okay so if you have a
playstation
yeah you're good you can get it if you
have a playstation 5 yeah is there
available okay yes
there's already a multiplayer component
this is a additional content to the
multiplayer component
and a story expansion absolutely as long
as it's free i'm down with them you know
3.99 free dining okay good because
they've been they've been
tearing everybody up anyway so god bless
no doubt
let me ask you i don't know if you're a
legends guy at all but um
does this interest you the legends mode
i already got it
nice i've already i love ghosts
we got a fellow ghost okay i think i put
like 140 hours into it
let's go no doubt no doubt so legends
vote is reserved i know someone stepped
away for a little minute
um king are you at least interested in
the
free 99 version of ghost okay well first
i got to get the
version period so what happened with me
and you guys already know that i haven't
um
logged into my playstation to to get
my two games that i do have digital with
it's only two is the last of us two and
it goes to shashima and i knew it was a
bad idea when i did that with ghost to
shashima
i knew i should have just brought it
physically because i do not trust
playstation to save my life
but at the same time it's just i haven't
there's no need to turn the box on
because there's nothing there for me to
play
there'll be something there for you with
a director's cut sir oh no it won't
right because again i i'm trying to get
to these new experiences
and if i do happen to go back to that
fine i think ratchet and clank will
actually be that game
oh okay yeah you're a ratchet attack
back on right because i'm i'm a huge
ratchet and playing fan i love it
and and you might say fraud alert on me
you're not such a huge ratchet clank fan
that you didn't buy it i don't think
ratchet and clank is worth 70 bucks
so at the same time when i can get a
bargain deal on it i will actually
purchase said game
but again and this is me standing on my
square
because had the game came out for 60
bucks
i would have said all right cool and i'd
have been in it's just
me not trying to push that forward
trying to make that a standard you know
and i don't think that
especially where we're at economically
as a culture right now i don't think
raising the prices on anything is doing
us any benefit right so at the same time
you can subsidize the price of that game
that the ten dollars doesn't need to be
uh
there oh yeah we know how we
probably upgrade give them the ten
dollars stupid tax and get in there
yeah i'll get in for that but you know
it's it's it's my unwillingness to
to conform to what they're trying to
make me do all right
here's my issue with a king i'm a
physical collector i want the the box of
the game
i don't want to put the ps4 disc in have
it install the ps4 version of the game
and there's two logos in the top bar
yeah i just i hate
it's so annoying i know they they're
adding features to turn that off
i don't even want to deal with it i'm
just going to wait for it to go on sale
you know
working games it's my responsibility to
buy the game but i'm not going to be
doing any coverage on the game so i
don't have to
and it just feels weird buying it for 63
dollars then buying it for 73 dollars
wow then you know and i and the death
training is another one that i've got on
pc already and
ps4 and i really want to get the
director's cut because that's one of my
favorite games ever
and goes to tsushima is one of the
greatest playstation games made of all
time
um i do love that game but look at look
at that release calendar
um the 12 minutes comes out the day
before
the psychonauts 2 comes out this week
august i'm in trouble bro
yeah yeah but i mean that's pretty good
for you because a lot of those games is
just straight the game pass
so that saves you a a boatload of cash
there
and um since since you know you you're
playing your passion because
you you see your physical games in the
background right now i did not know that
this was an issue where you're putting a
playstation 4 game and and the
playstation 4 logo and the playstation 5
logo was at the top i didn't know that
and had i did know that i would have
crazy jokes
[Laughter]
so you just explained that to me which
is absolutely hilarious
but at the same time that is an issue
for a lot of people right
that people are like probably suffering
and silence don't say anything
because this is the first time i'm
hearing this because it's not the first
time it's happening they are
suffering in silence because of a logo
or two versions
well he said he said he doesn't want to
deal with that
oh you you you're empathizing with g
struggle
god you know what my why my man gene got
to have two logos
there should be one logo up there let's
not stop playing with his screen time
and cut that out man you you're taking
up valuable resources
to put up another little logo get that
logo out of here
no we don't need that we need one logo
fight the good fight
my time is worth more than the money at
this point because we're so busy
all these games coming out we know king
we know the game is going to be 29.99 on
black friday two months later
i can't see this is where we are we're
some particles
right here we together right now we are
seeing eye to eye
i will be at the playstation venue when
they're 29.95
that's exactly what i feel you guys are
worth 29 29.95
and yeah you're gonna see me with my
stack you're gonna see my stack do this
because i'm going to target i'm getting
that buy one get one free
the last week of october you and i are
gonna go to target and we're gonna get
the desk training director's cut
yes and and the uh goes to sashimi
director's cut yes and whatever else
comes out
but if we get one free target wild skit
like
we can go in the aisles and i can hide
in the box and pop out
and grab and grabbed the kings
and popped back in i'm done with you
yo we can do no eugene we're gonna have
some fun
please do that so i can see the reaction
of the target staff
yeah i
year was uh man that game was awesome
that that that
that's a game i slept on initially so
proud to see you play it
yeah yeah because like initially when i
first started playing i was playing some
other stuff
i you know what i did i did the
look i am not into the whole either
people want to hear the japanese voices
and stuff
now look look when i watch it like
people about to be mad at me
i watch anime oh i'm watching the dubbed
okay look i don't have the time to be
trying to read
yeah yeah i can't like the
the text be coming up too fast i'm like
what do you think what are you saying
let me go back no i'm not i'm not doing
that i'm dubbed all the way so look i'm
listening watch enough japanese movies
and enough anime to stop doing
ignis he's been doing the nishkin now
since back in the day 20 years
that's the mask right there look that
story i thought was awesome the combat i
loved it man
i love just running up into a a a uh
controlled village and just forget going
stealth
nah man i'm coming in i'm cutting heads
off
when you announce it right you'll be
like i'm here i'm here
come see me i want to stand up matter of
fact all
come over here real quick so i can cut
you all down and do a nice little pose
yes i love it i love that game i did
legends a little bit
but the thing is i think i kind of
missed the wave because so many people
weren't playing it anymore and i
couldn't find
too many people to do the pvp with yeah
by the time i got into it
like i already played it i beat the game
later like months later
and then like almost everybody was done
with playing the pvp but i did enjoy
you know just going in with randoms and
doing like kind of like like control
yeah like some of the the missions like
that i did some of the storms
i thought dudes they got rid of they do
have right
uh everybody was done with what i'd be a
certain level through the raise i didn't
i didn't reach that level
i did do some of the story content with
brad you know kind of carried him even
though he had a higher level than me i
had to kind of put him on
on my back and put him in a book bag
and them adding additional content to a
mode that was already free
surprised everybody gave you more free
stuff that that was
quality that was that ten dollars you
spent the extra you already paid for
starbucks we talk about this game don't
don't add starbucks
i'm saying ten dollars don't mean
nothing to me you know
i'm gonna mean everything to me oh that
would beat everything to you
it dude it's a barrier mm-hmm it's a
barrett you know what it is
a very good point yesterday i went to um
a gas station right so i go inside the
gas station
i get a cup of ice a cup of ice 50 cents
we're in new york we know that yeah
right yeah
so get my cup of ice all right so i said
you know what let me get this juice
already had the juice joint
all right cool let me get some chips i
get the chips i give her a ten dollar
bill she gives me back a dollar i got
three bags of chips
a dollar with my ten
look over at the chick i'm like yo yo i
gave you a 10.
yeah yeah yeah those chips is two
dollars a piece
[Laughter]
the bag listen she had a 50 cent costco
bag
no no you had the 50 cent costco bag you
trying to chunk
i said men never flung somebody's stuff
bad disgusting three bags over give me
give my six dollars come on stop playing
with me king wasn't feeling that
at no point in time are you going to
gouge me just cause i
can't like she probably looked at my
wallet you know because i'm a fool like
that i'm one of those people to walk
around with a wallet
so she wasn't looking at the wall i was
like yeah i got a sucker tonight
no you don't i love my ten dollars
the world so that that's what ghosts
receive is ten dollars
it's cool but you know hey to each other
i'm just kind of telling you how to game
you calling me messi and lava la also
king play scarlet nexus king
i will yeah definitely do that yeah i
will no already sold me on the game no
doubt and then we got the raider blade
two pounds from chat
hello lords happy lord's day you already
know but uh slow-mo so you're all the
way in right you you're going
i'm all the way in on launch like look
i'm playing i'm playing a lot of the
other games
also like 12 minutes i've been waiting
for that for a minute videos on it
you know like but but like when when
when legends pop
you know i know i know some people who
will be
on and i'm like yes finally i got the
fan base to come back in for that two
days and then they go back out
goat is back you know what i'm saying
with the freezing condition
and we got we got the lipstick now we
got the japanese lipstick
we lit y'all i'm telling y'all right now
your legends is super lit
the pvp component they have raids y'all
it is destiny level mechanics
you know what i'm saying the fact that
they're giving you this actual
destiny level community it's the
mechanics
bro
listen man you got that sticky icky
island
and look we all know we were not happy
with the whole ten dollar lift thing and
whatever and then the ps5 unlocked uh i
mean it was already back compatible yeah
it was back compat free
but at least this is a good gesture to
the community and it's a really good
move
is it double logo free oh my god
shout out to sony doubling down because
they're showing
[Music]
it's a great game but it's cool it's
cool to see them to do the joint you
know what i'm saying
yo shout out to the lord of invites he
said that's a good two dollar final
house in the chat
this is the kick slow mo off this
heathen watches anime
and subbed also i would say take
slo-mo's knees but you don't want them
trust me
that's funny shout out to my fellow my
fellow scum cast
panda member fellow legion of scum deaf
singer yeah i i do want to tell you
though uh singer i hope your tea is flat
i hope you can't find no sugar for god
and i hope tea
time at high noon turns into something
completely different shout out to the
youtube have a great day
we got the raiden blade five passwords
so in the chat says ps5 is now
profitable
ups five fans enjoy your games but don't
believe what them ps5 execs have to say
they've been lying okay it's not
profitable
right oh we're gonna get let's move into
the transition
i love clark still got the master oh no
this is out of control
he's going into a sony top but he to go
y'all want to wear some masks that's
cool
it's my favorite game i had guys
want to just add i just want to add uh i
think slo-mo sold me on two games today
uh getting ghost shoes day one and um
scarlet nexus yeah that's what i'm
talking about
but yo icky island make sure y'all cop
you already know what it is
no doubt i'm really mad you have that
because it's sold out i couldn't get one
the message josh it was so loud too
shout out to some friends of mine i
wasn't going to get somebody he knows
who he is how are you going to put him
out there
really expensive right now there it is
it is that's exactly what you're
supposed to have on right there shout
out to oh shout out to movie
shout out shout out to the real games
out here
i love it i love it oh my god it's
pretty this premium content y'all but
look we gonna move on
we have we had all right before you pass
out it's hard as hell
we got now actually it's it's a
comfortable 68 degrees
okay yeah i'm not over here
[Music]
final topic for the day king had a lot
to say so i'm going to set him
up we want to talk about playstation so
what's going on
in our reference to i believe sub count
so it look looks like they posted a
stellar
uh five sony supposed seller financial
results yesterday
um not yes they were actually this week
as far as their first quarter of the
fiscal year
but also the company saw a 9.3
increase in income from um services like
playstation plus playstation now
however there was a significant decline
in playstation plus subscriptions
so there was some uh webcast i believe
um the sony chief financial officer
hiroki to can't pronounce to tolkie said
that they would just say or
officer yeah yeah officer
yeah i was so concerned about
pronunciating the name i
mispronounced that but um yeah so i said
as a result they said um
seeing it was an unprecedent increase in
playstation plus subscriptions last year
due to the worldwide lockdown stemming
from the pandemic as a result the dip in
the last two quarters isn't something
that the company is really concerned at
so he said look 104 is not a strong
number but we're looking at it but are
they looking at it as a declining trend
no so that was something i wanted to
talk about and then he reiterated his
point he said last year the stay-at-home
demand was so significant
in hindsight when compared to that
period last year as a trend it declined
but compared to the fiscal 2019 there
was an increase
so sort of like the pandemic coming into
play as far as their reasoning as far as
this decline but
king couldn't wait to talk about this to
the realm so uh king floyd is yours man
playstation
plus subscribers how are you can we on
time already yeah i know yeah
earlier all right so just uh uh to
address the situation where people are
yelling out playstation is profitable
right now
really just one person christopher hart
no it's it's
it's a lot of these little armchair
stock brokers
that that uh actually these these
armchair cryptocurrency dudes
that don't have a bitcoin to save their
soul um
who doesn't uh have a mutual fund or
who doesn't know what day trading even
smells like can actually sit here and
talk fiscals with you all right
let me give you the basic gist of the
whole situation
you start off at a huge negative any
business that's going in
it's uh you're using your capital to
actually gain
money so you're sinking your money in in
hopes that your money will recoup
so if i'm 600 million and i already
explained it on
twitter if i'm 600 million in the hole
imagine you go to your bank account
right now and you get
600 million in the hope if you make 200
million did you make any money
no you're still 400 million in the hope
now uh playstation is giving you the
positive reports of
what they made they're not going to tell
you what
they owe that's never going to be on a
fiscal report
all right so don't tell me if they're
profitable you don't understand what a
profit margin is if you don't know what
the budget was
right so you're talking from a point of
ignorance at that point
and that is that's that's dangerous
don't do that don't do stuff and stop
talking stuff that you don't know you
play games love them
it's got a game you played it love them
stop talking about the millions of
copies that are there
when you actually brought one now unless
you went out there and brought millions
in your distributor
that need to worry about the financial
reports of sony and what they're doing
and how you need to stock your store
shut up all right oh my god so now we're
talking about the declining numbers in
the playstation subscription service
right
um that is something that i think that
would have happened anyway because the
declining numbers actually you have to
show value inside your subscription
service
for it to actually grow right because
you can't look at microsoft and look at
sony and say
all right these dudes declined over this
period of time but microsoft is showing
a steady growth
at this point in time so that means that
they see value in this service and don't
see the value in this service
and this goes back to my my uh wish
of them doing date and date and actually
putting their ips that they hold so high
for no reason
um in this service that they can
actually
raise the fan base raise and get in and
i know jim dance moves ryan as a
businessman
he's a money man because the day that
they kick sean lady now gave him the
boot like italy
the next day playstation now was 10
bucks
right so yeah so that actually showed
that
where where the problems lie and where
the value should have been
right now i feel that giving a little
tweaks
to the method of playstation now that
they can actually raise the subscription
base
by putting actual value in there even if
you take damn date right let's say
you do this for a month let's say you
the game comes out
and it's inside like what hbo max does
you got 31 days to watch this movie
here if you missed the 31 day window
we'll watch it in the movie theater and
it'll come back 90 days later
right to the subscription service right
but you got that window in
that shows value that's not going to
stop people from buying
no what that is is going to actually
encourage buying
two questions yeah you've you've told me
and all you guys have told me goes to
sashimi has actually been one of the
best games
and has actually been adding value to
the same package of game
right so that will keep sony in the
trend set like
they will continue to add value to their
single-player games that will keep you
engaged
in their ecosystem and what we need to
do is move away from unit soul to
engagement time and numbers because
that is more valuable for these
companies
and if they can do that they can raise
subscriptions and
subscriptions will lead to a larger
profit margins
right so i just see a decline as a
the service is not offering what the
consumer wants
question that was my question to you
guys all right question before we get i
just wanted two things one
the to their point of the pandemic right
so you you firmly believe that it's the
quality of the service
yeah as opposed so so what do you say to
them when they say
look you know because of the you know
and the fact that i don't want to say
that
you know we're now getting out of it but
you know part of it is that now
you know there's a lessening so to speak
and they saying maybe that so you don't
agree to that level no because the covet
is affecting uh microsoft as well
and game pass numbers is going up but
microsoft did not
put up the numbers they don't ever do
for this last one they didn't put up
exactly they don't ever do but then you
hear it when they hit a milestone when
they bust in their mouth with halo head
out and they be like yo we're at 37.
oh my god like that okay
okay so you got that and then what about
you know the people would say
like their business model is not like
microsoft's like
they're still invested in hardware sales
and and
they're not invested in hardware systems
these these the
ignorant basis of that is because
they're attached to plastic
right these people are attached to
plastic they will always tell you about
hardware sales
where sony is attached to unit sales
in games if the if the market has
switched from physical
to digital which is 70 percent of their
sales
they are attached to units sold per game
where they actually
make a profit they do not make a profit
off of hardware sales until it reaches a
certain point
and the chipsets come down in price
where they can actually make a revenue
off of the system
they do not at this point so that is
irrelevant at this point with unit sales
they if they can eliminate that box
right now and have you just purchase
stuff that they make a profit on which
will be those controllers
which will be the games they will do
that in a heartbeat
but they can't do it because the
infrastructure is not ready yet
okay at the same time when people keep
saying that they're attached to this
they're attached to this because the
market isn't ready for them to switch
the market was ready for them to switch
to digital that's what i did
that's what i was gonna ask you what
like because at the end of the day
historically we've seen sony when it
when there's a shift the big shift is
some sometimes i would say like a one
foot forward approach
but you know whether it be the jim ryan
shift or what have you right
right they don't seem as fully committed
to that transition to that digital thing
or in in format that structure
like you're saying how microsoft was to
their detriment because let's be honest
when microsoft now we look back at it
and probably look at i can say hey it
was the right move
but at the time the base was not ready
for that and there was a lot of negative
pushback so
do you think it's the case because of
sony saying to themselves look
our base one with the exclusive the
hardware
the console stuff like we're not ready
to do such an aggressive shift
but more of a gradual one and to your
point
you know jim ryan is complacent with
that all right so i say this
the real sony fans there's only 560 of
them oh god
these are there's only five hundred and
six they're returning
it was broken and they went out there
and they support it regardless of what
and then you have the million um people
that have ratchet and clank
right but then you have 10 million out
in the wild right
so you have these idiots on twitter
running around getting
in your show bro 10 million show
but your most popular ssd
games okay god bless the ring
game only sold to a million of you dudes
your sony exclusive return
only sold to the action are you implying
that exclusives are they don't buy
games
don't buy games so you imply they are
conflating the
the the value of uh exclusive that that
exclusive truly did not drive the market
the way they claim
is that dance moves ryan knows this
right he knows that he has the figures
out there he knows
he knows you he every last one of you
dudes that brought eternal blessings
all five hundred and six y'all y'all are
the dudes that are actually keeping sony
back from greatness
you guys right i bought it
because he only cares if you say they
only care about that fan base
the fan bases they don't want to step on
their fan-based toes there's only 560
000 of you dudes that they worrying
about
so let's let's not worry about you guys
let's worry about
the nine million that that purchase that
ain't doing what they're supposed to do
let's get these man to do
what they're supposed to do and stop
worrying about you
500 are you implying that they are the
vocal minority they're the loudest dudes
they're holding back the real dudes
want to be heard and you loud mouth 560
just messing with up man
you gotta stop calling them loud
and tired of you dudes i'm part of the 9
million i don't want to be hurt
that was fire bars i had to get out
those are fun we gotta open it up man
we'll be let's get to you man like we'll
be
what's your whole thing obviously the uh
playstation subscriber
decline thing and you know your thoughts
on sony the infrastructure
as a business i think a lot of it is
declining lockdown okay matter of fact i
said it six months ago and a dude on the
podcast told me i was nuts
um i mean when everybody's confined in
their properties
yeah what do you expect them to do i
mean we have people playing games that
have never played games no that's the
fact that's a fact yes
matter of fact my son-in-law's dad
the guy that hates video games you know
he he called me up one day he goes hey
you ever hear this thing called uh
called destiny
[Laughter]
i
[Laughter]
you know what i'm not promoting any
leadership
right now that's your favorite because
you know
do you want a second job you want a
third job
we're providing a service during tough
times
you know the bottom line is it really
i'm gonna be honest i'll say it on time
i don't really care
which company makes more money which one
loses more money because they're not
paying me
i feel that i i keep all these companies
afloat because i buy almost every game
that comes out on every single platform
and you know i buy the merchandise like
king you know with the statues i buy all
kinds of crazy stuff man that i will
never use my grandson's gonna have to go
through this stuff one day and toss it
in the trash
you know and i've got rooms full
but my thing is
i don't think because i subscribe to
both i have game pass matter of fact i
had it when it was they used to do like
a beta on it
i've had playstation you know now for a
while
the game pass games are better because
on the playstation there's a lot of
games in there that i will never
ever play ever because i'm like a lot of
gamers i'm not into anime or
jpr you know rpgs or anything like that
i love it
that was very old school
i'm not even into those type
and there is a lot of those in there you
know in the playstation now
you know a little collection but every
once in a while i do find a decent game
on there and i do play it
but seldom do i play anything on it no
doubt and then again with game pass
i'm sort of the same way i don't really
play a lot of the games in game pass
okay why i subscribe to it i don't know
but i mean you know here lately there
are some new games coming out on it like
12 minutes
yes not so much i'm waiting for this
game i've been waiting for it forever
12 years there are some games pretty
much
and i see you interested for back for
blood you're a horror guy
i i already pre-ordered bachelor oh so
you ain't even wait you're like i'm
buying that man
yeah unlike a lot of people i still buy
a ton of games with them during game
passes
which works out because i still get the
uh little turn-ins
for your rewards yes but to me it
doesn't really matter much i want to see
both companies do well
no doubt because as long as they're
going at each other's throats
there's competition if one gets a hand
above the other
then the other one's going to get lazy
king would disagree with you king wants
complete and utter destruction of
playstation i want big bang eat little
bang
um well i don't i don't well see king
says that all the time but i don't think
he really needs it
i agree a lot of people think he does
because i want to assimilate them like
the book
i mean you know listen
everybody everybody everybody misses my
whole point in this whole thing yeah i
would rather not buy a playstation
console and just buy one console and
have their games over here
i mean we're making a superior hardware
right so
pc superior
[Laughter]
be worried about who's looking through
my camera at me when i'm doing whatever
oh my god that's why my camera you know
turns there's no exact thing
if i'm playing my game and my camera
turns from white to red i know
somebody's recording me
well you know that's mark zuckerberg oh
my god
so all that you and your spyware and all
that
i'm i'm about to say no to you
and yes to where i want to play you're
going to play in your clothes
environment
you've already got spyware king it's
right there oh it's gonna sell
the phone yeah i was going to say that
that's nice you can't you can't can't
avoid big brother
stop looking at you wherever stop trying
to get me to gain weight you want me
all right i don't want gaming
invitation man we got we got the best
performing games
and we got all the games that's what i'm
telling you absolutely that's a lot and
i'm gonna tell you
they'd be like hold on did you get
update 37.
i'm gonna have to call for that tattoo
back now sir you're gonna get the chance
yo cause we'll be like bc too there's a
pc heavy yeah
i'm talking you know i'm talking through
a pc that makes coffee every morning yes
oh my god i got i got a goofy one over
here too guess what i do
i turn it on to do podcasts i turn it
off to go
upstairs to play a game machine
this is why you feel like i don't want
that
i don't want nasty names don't you take
it because of my naked soul
and post in the moment
your camera because the bigger issue why
do i hire you
why do i have to disable my camera to
play spy boy
spiderman why do i why are you playing
spiderman
yes you should play that with a 30 90.
you know it's crazy
first of all if i had five thousand
dollars to buy 30
that is true it is very hard to give but
what i did do
is i played it on my hundred dollar box
i guess
where did you play sir where did you
play what's what service provided you
that sir
check this out check this out guess what
experience i had the same one that you
had
fulfilled dominance maximus experience
you can tell me i can see the pixels on
the courthouse better
i don't care i played it for free
[Laughter]
but listen guess guess what i didn't
have to worry about nasty ned taking new
pictures of me and posting it on
time
the dude in the xbox chair looks like
duke nukem tell him i'm lying
raiden blade five pounds of a check it
took the ps4 five years to start making
profit
stop listening to them enjoy your ssd
upgrade and the games you have
and then i believe hold on looks like
raiden blaze still again
yo they got to stop he said raiden blade
with the
five pound he said the chipsets are
still high not cheap
the price is still high unless they are
using cheaper and lower technology in
the ps5
and then sycamore with the five dollar
super chat he got to start calling will
me duke nukem duke nukem is speaking the
truth
no doubt respect y'all need to have this
man on the show
often yes we do we we love will be hood
aka
you don't know what he did to me raiden
watch that movie after the show raiden
blade with the five pound super chat
king be honest you want
playstation destroyed before you want
revenge for sega
so that's that's what that is i'm being
honest i told you i want them to
assimilate what part don't you get oh
hold on miss a couple raiden blade again
five pound game pass announcement
only when it hits that milestone until
then xbox won't say anything until that
point
smitty smith five dollar super chat so
laura king are you saying there isn't
value in ps later salute the book of x
um raiden blade again i miss you do
people understand the difference between
game pass and gold member versus ps plus
and ps now numbers and then on rain and
blade again i'm going back with y'all
chris hart you need to understand
finance development and distribution
first
if you don't get it be quiet and i think
yes i am now caught up gene because this
has devolved into some crazy pc
masturbation
gene that's the question everybody wants
to know
now i think you said your personal
affairs
you don't have to answer that question
good good stuff so gee what about you
like uh playstation now um
subscribers that whole thing and to
king's rant about on the ex
the exclusive um value versus the
overall numbers and console sales stuff
like that
uh i am gonna kind of clap back at king
here for a little bit so we're gonna
get him but he's he games in his
basement naked around your statues
[Music]
oh
yes so the reason why the xbox numbers
haven't declined
a month i'll touch on the exact sony
issue but yeah um
is because microsoft has made probably
and these numbers aren't out there
they're not official so i'm just making
stuff off the top of my head
probably a 12 to 15 billion dollar
investment in game pass
yeah over the past year with the
bethesda acquisition
with the x cloud uh investments with the
third party stuff that they're they're
buying out outright and bringing over
and with their own first party
development it's got to be above 10
billion dollars at this point and we're
talking about
just this year alone right and sony has
not made those kinds of investments in
their subscription services and it's not
even close
right uh so that's why you're seeing
those uh disparaging numbers and
and xbox is doing it over three
platforms the phone the console correct
so their numbers aren't down and sony's
numbers are not down
year to date they're down month over
month
go back to wilmie's point is and i'm
sure everyone in chat everyone
in this group can can relate the entire
country
is going away on vacation this summer at
some point
everyone's shutting down everyone's kind
of taking a little break
everyone's going on vacation in droves
uh last year there was a big
issue with with availability as people
were transitioning to work from home and
now we're seeing a big issue
with people just taking mass vacations
this summer and not being available
um and the other thing that i would
touch on uh with that and and why
somebody's
down wait i agree all right so you're
saying when you go on vacation you
cancel your subscription
no no but i'm getting to that it's
longer there's less people home
so it's it's not down year to date it's
down month to month right
uh so the next thing i would touch on is
it's uh over the past couple of months
the unemployment rate between the ages
of 16 and 19 has dropped 20 percent
right so those people are all going back
to work they're letting their
subscriptions
lapse anyone who's buying the three
month cards one at a time
they're not home anymore gaming they're
out doing so you're talking about the
broke boys
tcl crab king all right all right i got
it i got it it's a reverse of what we
saw last year with everyone being home
and then having more time to game it's a
complete reverse of that where people
are now
traveling going away on vacation they're
going back to work
especially that age range of 16 to 19
the unemployment rate is down
uh 20 percent over the past few years
i got to call fraud on this because i'm
going to say i'm just going to say this
and it's
it's an eloquent point that you're
pointing out which is really nice
i just got to say which is really nice i
i just got to say with a fraud alert
yeah i just got to say that at no point
in time
am i going on vacation or i'm starting a
new job do i say
netflix you're done
at no point do i say that right so
usually what you do is you take your
credit card
and you add that to your subscription
service
and you pay now what you're explaining
to me is people is on these
month-to-month cards
and they only can and this will this
will really explain the fear of the
playstation base
because they cannot substantiate a
subscription service
new to financials and things that are
going on into their lives
this is why that they are opposed to gay
past because they cannot
if they cannot afford the subscription
right consistently for listening
on vacation and they don't want to come
back and go and go to sushima not
working
oh they don't want to come back and
definitely got in
all
the fair in the playstation fan base
because
that fear is not prevalent in a
successful
fan base it's just i understand it now
if if
going through what you're saying is
because people are going back to work
people are going on vacation if they're
cancelling their subscriptions
it really makes no sense but it makes
sense
you understand like i really understand
that it makes sense but it makes no
sense because at no point in time
if i'm going to get a new job or if i'm
going on vacation
am i going to look over at my
subscription services and say well
you know i'm going to cabbo
let me let me get you with the 40 chests
whoa all right go ahead
oh here we go 16 to 19 age demographic
was at a historic high unemployment rate
and now it's it's come down
almost 20 over the past few years but
they got more money so 16
17 and you know 18 for the most part
they can't even go out and get a credit
card because he can't have a credit card
under the age of eighteen so they can't
my daughter had a credit card since she
was ten years old
because if you're a proper parent you
make sure that your kids have credit
cards and they're able to do things
because you're teaching them finances
early no i will not
bend the knee today
the 10 to 16 year old demographic is
going on vacation more those are month
month card buyers
where the parents are going into game
stop investing absolutely king agrees
with you because
and that's what king's theory is not to
country g but king's theory goes in line
with what you just said because he
firmly believes that the people who
again these are kings thoughts their
minds he firmly believes that the people
who are of the opposite camp that do not
like game pass
the reason they are so opposed is
because he feels that they cannot
maintain a month-to-month year
commitment in a credit card to sustain
the subscription continue
right and then i'll just say the 16 to
19 demographic is going
back to work they don't have time to
play video games because they're also
probably in college too
uh and i'm sure that's a huge bulk of uh
playstation's
user base no doubt no no shout out to
daniel he said i love how cog translates
for key breaks it down so it doesn't
sound less harmful yes yes
the way you do it the way i say it the
broke boys can't
substitute a subscription service and
they went back to college and it was
like
i want to have ramen noodles or i want
to have game packs i can't
buy game pass i'm eating my noodles
[Laughter]
moving oh do we got every before
everyone else got their balls
before i get you sleep on this subject
in reference
i don't think i i'm sorry um
in regards to that last point i i
actually kind of feel like there's two
completely different demographics i
think the people
who are cr who criticize game pass
are not people who really have actually
have a problem with game pass
but they just like to criticize xbox so
they
they they may even actually have game
pass themselves
but they just don't want to admit it i
believe that there are also
people who who also they they still have
ps plus and they will probably will
never get
they probably are the kind of people
that just like they throw their credit
card on it put it on the auto refresh
and they just
forgot about it you don't even know how
much it costs they're just coming out of
the car
i think it's a i think it's a completely
different demographic a gamer in
the playstation uh uh install base as
well as
xbox install bases as well where they
like i have a friend who
like every now and then he goes oh man i
forgot to re-up on on xbox
and i'm like what you you you re we mean
real
like to me it's like i don't even know
what you're talking about
and he's like yeah i do the three-month
thing and i'm like oh i
like i completely forgot that was a
thing right i think there is
that kind of demographic of gamer
regardless of platform that
continues to do that and maybe just
right now like what whatever
the you know the stuff that eugene
eugene's talking about where
you know things are going on where that
kind of gamer is like
you know what i'm gonna pause on that
real quick i'm gonna come back once i
get some things done
or you know maybe i don't believe my
life financially and stop worrying about
my hobbies and worrying about real life
let me go get my real life together so
shout out to all the playstation
subscribers that decided you know what i
got to get real life together let me
just cut this playstation stuff that
they doing
that's what they said that's exactly
what they said they looked at all their
subscription services
i've used that netflix bar that espn
can't do without it what am i not that
playstation now how the hell did that
get
out continue slow-mo continue
no no i i just think it's it's that's
what it is
it's that particular demographic and and
like it wasn't rising at all next month
it's back up
or even even as what gene was talking
about in regards to
a lot of numbers being inflated with
pandemic stuff
like all across the board yeah gaming
yeah it wasn't
anything tech anything that you could
enjoy
in the comfort of your home went up when
people were stuck in their homes and
with this delta variant going around
you know like look the state of maryland
i live in maryland and the state of
maryland went like well i guess we're
going back yeah
yeah there's some lockdown modes and so
like
oh and we going back to lock now why
didn't i'm just saying
look look i i can't i could agree with
you king if it's like let's say if
it's more than a month and we sit we see
a trend
yeah a trend then it's like all right
i like it it's month-to-month not year
to year
i love it i love it because next year
they're gonna be like well we had a
slight decline
in uh playstation subscribers
and what we feel like we need to do is
we need to more
add more value to the situation
and then microsoft said we gonna drop 10
to 12 billion
into our stuff we're betting on
ourselves
people thought microsoft was microsoft
was fools
but they said we're going to put our
first party games in there and then the
detractors said
well y'all don't got games anyway okay
so why would you care if they put the
first party games in if they don't got
games
oh you saw that forza and you was like
oh that's going in there like that
oh and they saw that gears in it that
going going there
that's in there like that like oh
well you ain't gonna get third party
support yeah they're not gonna outride
us in there like that
like so now the the the barriers is
being broken down
you actually see the whole question and
then you don't see
value here we cannot deny that there's
no
value over there that's why it's a
steady deal it's not
then it's gonna be from month to month
so next month you're gonna say
yo you know they just getting back off
vacation and um
they didn't re-up yet it's gonna be the
next month
they just started school so you know how
it is
and then the next month is gonna be it's
the holiday
little timmy needed no shoes just
kidding are you replying to those
excuses
that's what we're doing it will be go
pull shifting and moving and shaking
until we figure out who it is
that's what this is you cut stuff that
ain't worth it
[Laughter]
oh okay i see what you do let me get
these two fish
make it worth it and then i get my balls
up because king is all one
raid and play with the five pound super
chat people out here will meet hood is
dangerous
that man set up a thousand dollars on a
hot chip or the tattoo challenge for
king
roomie is the man not the best way they
are shook of will be in here
be afraid to wield me i'm gonna tell you
right now yeah yeah yeah that's a fact
raider blade you know i i i wonder what
that top tier patriot oh god
i know who he is it's gone i could use a
nice yakuza tattoo on my back
oh my gosh
that's what that's why i was playing
halo with attic we were we were you know
trying to
fire against king to get a new you get a
new team
brady blade two possible shot i'm glad
to see will be hood all the day
and damn damn it move me move me damn it
okay here it goes
oh yeah then it says ready again hey i
can go on holiday hey i could go on
holiday
take my game pass with me really shout
out to rayne g4 5
super chat king looking like the locks
right now versus sony is dipset
damn all right playing with the five
hours of jack king play spider-man naked
because he wants to feel the br
flame he wants to feel the breeze
he wants to feel the breeze of swinging
through new york city from his
playstation 4.
who needs a dual sense am i right we're
going to have some talks in this next
meeting flame throughout the controller
anyway um and i think okay dj bird oh
dose two dollar subjects stop it king
hit that voice all right so that's it so
look i'm
pretty much in agreement with slovo here
you know what i said i
i need to agree with you i need to see
more data before i
make these bro bull proclamations like
king
you know as far as that's why i'd be 95
right because they scared to say what
i'm saying
because i see it i see it happening
y'all gonna be like nah the house and i
don't fight and all crispy
and i'm outside on the lawn drinking the
juice i told him
you will be crowned the prophet once
again if you go
if swami the lord and we will get you
your turban with you with your jewel in
the center
if we see another month or two or
whatever next quarter
and we see this continual trend and then
i will agree but i do agree with slo-mo
in the sense that
yeah the pandemic coming back we got to
see how that trend is
and to to gene's point though we need to
see
game passes numbers because they still
have been quiet since the last
announcement
shockingly we know i'm sure they're
going up right now
because as much as we clowning sony is
transparent with
they're not transparent okay they are
not transparent
we doing this let me see the deficit
they you telling me what i want to hear
not what i need to know see this is the
difference where you know
this this is what i don't like they are
fake transparent oh no
you know when you come home and you did
something felonious that you wasn't
supposed to do
this and your mother said how was your
day and you said good
because she wasn't specific so your
question
your thing is they're not specific with
the deficit of the hardware debt
what they do what sony does best better
than any console developer
any big company is they lie by omission
right they lie by omission so
by um omitting i know you're going back
all right yeah you didn't technically
lie they didn't tell you i know
you ain't asked specifically this
but this no no no i i i agree to that to
some respect i think
i agree i think all kinds yeah you're
right but all companies do it but i will
give king this and it's not the sony
back
i do feel this generation specifically
there is a lack of transparency in
specific things
right and they won't tell you
specifically like that ssd
shout out to you being a true later boy
here we go shout out to you i saw you i
saw you
i'm in the program
i was going for the wd what is it the
850 whatever
mark cerny tweeted it yeah whatever
whatever tweet he tweeted that's the one
i'm going with
and to my dismay all these fiends
snatched up best buy walmart amazon i
could not
find this
digital and the problem is they like
yeah but it's a three to
three week back order so i'm in the beta
program but i can't test it because at
the end of the day
there were other options out the
eurogamer they have some other options
but to me i feel comfortable going with
mark cerny said
last time with the samsung 980 uh evo
i went for the evo digital boundary
tested yo i just looked today it was it
was
i heard you put other stuff in there and
it just run just fine
at the end of the day there were three
particular models i went what were
looking for
but specifically the western digital was
the one i really wanted and
or you could do my the other option is
like
delete chicken oh [ __ ] it no delete
your console gamers
only for you to scroll through your
libraries
give me my joy of scrolling and clicking
on
instantaneously when you buy it
i never click on it i don't
let me know what happened so i want to
know if you know about what i ripped the
wings off you got to be
leaning out with his butt oh my god oh
man
anyway you got to put the joy in but you
got to put a heat sink yeah that's
the thing that had me mad because
the joint that i that the ones that are
all of it are available
are the non-heat seek models cause like
oh i found it and i'm like wait no
this ain't it there's
even though i say delete your game don't
even bother with this yeah
if you want to go this route yes
a non-heatsink one and then you buy like
a ten dollar heatsink
off of amazon and put on top of it i
just don't want i don't want to do the
esd
and the static discharge and the thing
i'm i'm real particular i just want it
done i sort of put it in there
leave it alone be done i don't want to
put on there
you know what he really want to do
what's that what was that when his joint
break out
oh god when it break out and sony just
be like
they're going to do all laddie on them
[Laughter]
with the all daddy all that
specifically from the samsung 980 plus
was that it performs
faster than the internal ssd of the
what i want to do is make that the
default install
for my primary joint i'm with you slow i
just that's
what i want with them so you mean to
tell me slow-mo there's something out
there faster than what they put in there
god here we go
yeah you're out there in the streets
that's better than what they said it was
yeah you know with their with their i o
and and these ssds this was unheard of
this was the most amazing thing that
could ever be so you mean in the streets
there's already some out there that
surpass it whatever we thought we was
getting what's good
yeah seven thousand megabytes per second
yeah so you actually
and they didn't do nothing but do a pull
button but i'm just saying like
so we we actually didn't need it like
that because it was something already
out there better
okay you implying that they they
conflated the value of their ssd and
that the plate the pc already has an ssd
that's faster
that will be applying sir what i'm
saying is everything else is weaker so
they said let's make a faster ssd
as far as the hallway you're messing
compared to the series
because this is going to go on yeah i'm
so sorry yes yes
this is sorry not
shout out to the flame with the two five
two chat all the good fun i know i'll
mess with you brother you are hilarious
by the way
but look we gotta wrap up flame i like
to feel the wind yeah oh hold on we got
oh my man i
and mike you already know a lot of dude
follows which a lot of dudes talking
down on game pass owners not
buying games out here in game sharing
relationships with other grown men
what yo he said one game two straws yo
iron bike is loose yes
let's get this poll so we get everybody
out of here new iop
log that poll this week king will love
this one with the
mpd sales success of multi-player
third-party titles
that are also day and date in game pass
outriders mlb the show and potentially
back for blood
do you think a single player title can
have
similar day and date npd success
in game pass the choices are a no
the service will only cater to
multiplayer and co-op games
to drive the engagement model b
yes gameplay game pass games will still
encourage
paid sales for single-player games day
and date or c
i don't care let's deflect and talk
about those playstation plus describers
subscriber dump stuff
so shout out to the entire bro i want to
shout out to
you first i want to shout out my homie
from lords of gaming.net god to see you
in the flesh once again doing our
convention
one two like we do meta map packs east
and now we're back
at play nyc my man gene
shaft meyer do i got it
i got it i got it this time my man where
can the five people find you what's
going on
uh you can tell me on twitter 37 gene 37
cogs got some tweets with me on it right
now you can just go to his page you
click on my name
and i just want to remind you that i'm
still hungry from the lunch you didn't
find me yesterday
and king uh i miss seeing you man and
and thanks for thanks for hanging out
with me next time i i would definitely
i tried so hard and and i really let me
let me i don't
think you guys know enough that gene is
probably one of the hardest working
dudes
um he he goes to damn near all the shows
that we go to
and if you ever see him in his element
you know um
he's a real journalist a professional
you know um he got the falcon
interview and that was a beautiful i
mean to watch you in your element was
something a beauty to behold
right and actually seeing uh how
meticulous you are with certain things
you had your notepad and he was
definitely taking down notes and stuff
like that
and i really better we had the blazer he
had the yeah the reggie fields are made
of black
he came out with the with with the party
but chill yeah and that's what's what
what was up
um and then and the knight saw him in
his element as well
yeah and i think he is a low-key mutant
um because he was at one yeah
we teleported from one party i don't
know
downtown boston yeah i don't know he's
like yo
i'm at this spot this party's trash but
i'm gonna go to where y'all at because
this was lit
and in five minutes he was there he was
i turned around i'm drinking my drink he
like yo i'm like yo
how did you get here i'm very time
efficient yeah
yeah yes you are yeah i want to shout
you out
yeah brother it's always a pleasure to
work with you i mean absolute
professionalism and then
the cool thing what i like about doing
like working with gene is that
when he finds something that he is
interested in
you have to pay attention because that
could be the one so he he like bee
lines his focus is razor sharp yeah you
once you pull out the capture card it's
over you know he that's the game he like
and shout out to him man because again
he found so many gems you know all the
time all the shows we do and stuff like
that
i still always tell the four guys story
because i was clowning this man slow mo
in my mind in my mind i was like that's
the game you're gonna cover okay
i looked at the game and i'm like all
right who's going like this right
old girl decrepit cog not understanding
the industry
uh gene was ahead of the curve she was
so ahead and a
brother that that that did so well for
log then
and just again his passion for games and
indies and everything man so salute to
gene
always an absolute pleasure with the
smoke today with the smoke for the king
yeah anyway
those two are mvps man they've been
holding it down for a minute so salute
to you on that and again
go towards the gamer.net cause he's got
some stuff up there right now
check that out and of course i would be
remiss if we did not
celebrate my brother will be hood gaming
behind the box
aka duke nukem affectionately now in the
realm
aka deborah i'm always going to remember
how much you got on my drink homie yeah
that's my bike you know when he super
chatted one time
he said i did that to you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that you almost died from oxford now but
he was if he was really here he said cog
yo if this man about to die he's like
i'm not gonna have this man
dude yeah he's a real one yeah yeah yeah
i was messaging cog i might look man you
know this is gonna cause king a problem
just yeah he was will
will told me oh you didn't have to do
the tattoo and stuff huh
and listen let me tell you something if
i put it there first of all i'll put it
there not thinking
that you existed in the world because i
didn't know you did yeah we thought that
would be the unattainable tier that we
would never have
i said i will put something foolish no
one's going to pay for it
because i thought we just had like
playstation dudes that didn't have any
breads
along comes a spider
brother where can i find people find you
what you got going on sir
oh you can find me on youtube gaming
beyond the box
every wednesday night at 8 pm eastern
with myself and my degenerate crew
and we do tons of game streams review
streams all that good stuff
we don't do any writing or that good
stuff because i'm not gonna lie we're
lazy
and i just feel like our opinions aren't
that important so yeah well what i like
about i'm sorry
and you can find me on twitter unless
you're one of the 100k that i've blocked
yes you've blocked the entire twitter at
this
and it's only fan boys i just don't deal
with it very well i don't have a low
tolerance you know
you get older in age your your tolerance
you know
gets a lot smaller and you can find me
on
facebook pretty much everywhere just
like when will me hood
you'll be amazed where i pop up
porn hub no time
by the way
this is the first two hours and somebody
better take a note of this
yes not one curse word just came out of
my mouth yes
you are you're on fire you know how i
know i i respect you brother
listen i i know i know how gaming behind
the box gets down
and i respect you don't say you're
covering the realm on the lord's day you
know what i'm saying
and see the last time you and king were
on our show you guys uh we're out of
your element too
yeah it's quite entertaining yes
[Laughter]
like i said thank you for pulling up man
always a pleasure love what you guys do
in the community the tournaments and
bringing people together actually
playing games which is actually dope
shout out to fork
i'm gonna be working with husk very soon
me and him got something cooking up
tomorrow every night all right
yes he got something hooking up tomorrow
like i said the whole crew man it's just
a fun bunch and they just they don't
care they're going to do them
and i love them about them they they
going and and for everybody that doesn't
know in your chat
you guys were the inspiration for gaming
beyond the box that's great
thank you that you guys are the very
reason the show exists
oh that was mm-hmm you gotta think it's
the only reason show exists
damn it oh forte i see what you said uh
write it out
because i'm by myself i see what you
said i got it i got it
um hold on one second because uh yeah
slow but but your forte that's hooked to
hit the realm up with something crazy
right now so i'm going
yeah yeah yeah so what i'm gonna do do
me a favor
forte hit slow mo with that so i could
put that out because i got to do it you
put it as an image
right just by the fact just write it out
just write it out and i'll take care of
it but anyway
so that's that's that slow-mo
dps podcast you already know scumcast
what is going on where can the fine
people
find you sir oh yeah well first off uh
thank you thank you for having me on i i
love to chop it up with the fellas
i love mess around with king and
it's good to meet eugene and will me so
it's
um you can find me at slo-mo backslap on
youtube
twitch and twitter on youtube i i do dps
podcast that's damage per second podcast
with the homie gaming forte every
thursday night it's nine p.m eastern
standard
thursday uh we alternate between my
channel his channel this thursday will
be
on my channel so come check us out we're
normally arguing
one another about something but we do
tend to get deep into these gaming
topics and and
and just the tech and just all the ins
and outs of game development we just
love to talk
talk that stuff and they do wear
clothing and they wear clothing
we do wear clothing and they are on pc
that's rare
um about my channel i do i do do a lot
of videos uh
similar to gene i i like to get into my
indie bag so a lot of the games that
everyone's enjoying now def's door i was
talking about dev's door back in like
when the idea xbox showcase came out
i was talking about that then extension
impact i was talking about junction
impact before that blew up
so if you want to look at like some find
out what
what's new that's coming out on the
horizon check my channel i'll check the
videos out
uh on twitch i'm playing everything
because i play everything i beat about
41 games last year
i'm up to about 16 this year so far so
i'm always playing something different
you know come through on twitch
uh hang out with the brother we'll be
playing a shooter one day and then a
tail till kind of game the next day so
you know it's all good
and uh again like slow backslap on
twitch
twitter twitter twitter yeah so yeah
come on through
and uh i appreciate appreciate the
invite you guys have a good one
i appreciate you slowing down again one
number one always appreciate you holding
down the realm you know what i'm saying
you'll be in there
bam hammer you you'll be catching you
awful with their heads and i love it
shout out to you i don't like to pull
out the sword too much and when it
happens
when the sword comes out it must be
bloody before it goes
hard so salute to you or that and then
again
love again dps you guys the perfect
synergy with you and forte
absolutely hilarious and shout out to
you on your personal channel because a
lot of times
you're up on a lot of these indie games
a lot of games that
are very i would call obscure that
people sleep on and don't
know about and are actually smashes and
i love when you do that type of coverage
man so salute to you then of course you
you always got your destiny slander and
your pc master race landed so we got it
you know we got
you on that one i mean like i call
myself pc
master race i mean like i just
recognized
oh that's all that's all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
i recognize where you know a lot of the
originality and gaming starts at
and then eventually you know spreads to
you know consoles it is what it is right
and i all i want you guys to know is
that like look we haven't
come to what you're talking about
because
you incorporate nasty ned anyway
and we're going to have to leave the pc
master is where they are
until you can banish ned the room he's
the guy
causing the problem i would like to stay
in my wall garden where
ned is not right now i want to do
something real special courtesy of
gaming forte my man hat the other half
of dps podcast
damn it's in the chat right now go get
it that spider-man
remastered and like kick said what do we
call the kids the bro
the broke boys who who didn't let they
subscription ran out you could go get
spider-man right now because of course
that's that's probably the version that
forte didn't play oh yeah
that's that that's his version i'm glad
he's
giving it to somebody that um is less
fortunate
or you know because it means come on you
know playstations
oh my god so no no seriously salute to
him yeah that's that's what's up
give back that's my boy man that's what
us xbox dudes do we give back
all the xbox guys have enough to get
back we got we got we got we get well we
gotta help them up they can't keep their
subscription
oh my god
[Laughter]
listen man it is all good man again
appreciate you slow everyone coming
through many things forte
have yo listen yo subscribe to dps
subscribe to gaming4t subscribe to slow
mo backslash individual channels because
they do dps
on both channels so again catch them
live and again please
my man will meet hoodies out there
gaming behind the box support them
catch them on twitter just don't get
blocked don't say that slick he will
block you crazy
quick make sure you just make sure your
mouth ain't slick and of course please
support lawyersgaming.net
again the love for play nyc we felt it
it was cool we got a ton more content
coming up gene already know the team i
mean hitting them with a lot of videos
and stuff like that but that's all
i got next week big show again we're
gonna have some more fun and also send
some love to solve an addict they are
under the weather they're not feeling
well
please send us a like try to give it to
college try but it is what it is
on that note we got all super chats king
we're good we're good we're good you
didn't even say
mine oh my bad you're here
to get to wherever he need to get to i
don't know what he's trying to do
what you got going on sir where can i
find people find you
well
[Laughter]
also um the the the story of little man
is being done
oh yes because the story of little man
uh involves treachery uh to the highest
and in our community
um it has to be shine the light has to
be shined on an individual
but at the same time i don't want to
implement anybody that's into the
situation so
i'm trying to explain the story without
um
when i'm being hateful without being
bitter yeah i have to do with a lot of
attack right and
and a lot of times you don't you don't
eloquate your words
perfectly because words are used as
weapons
and i do not want a person canceled i
just want the person called to the
congregation yes the answer for their
crimes
factions all right so so that's that's
what i want because i don't want because
i
i notice when you weaponize people
people are just destructive
and you cannot actually control what
somebody else
do so when i do put it out it must be
set in a way
that i don't weaponize individuals
towards a person
that's nothing that i ever want done
correct no matter what somebody else
does
you cannot do that to somebody else but
oh wolverine is done
i chose to hold it back because of
the play ny information i want that
traffic going to lognet
um when these guys are out here working
and this is work guys because a lot of
times you think that we're having so
much fun
but uh to hold the conversation to get
the the bits and stuff like that and to
upload this stuff and to get this stuff
out to you this stuff is only done
here it's only done at gaming.net
all right so you're not going to find
these games no place else unless you go
to a dragon
uh runaway dragon tv where he's covering
stuff there because his feet is on the
ground he's working right now on these
streets we outside
when you go to see hip-hop gamer hip-hop
gamer feat is always in the streets he's
always politicking he's always working
and i think i need you guys to go to his
channel to like
follow and subscribe and definitely
support that man because he's getting
into
interviews and he's working very hard
and i don't see the numbers that he
should have
um i don't ever pray for myself i pray
for others
i say this to say go to lognet support
these dudes
because these are our journalists that
we're supposed to
you know support yes i would love to see
jean
stay with us forever but also i want
gene to get
paid exactly what i feel he's worth and
if i can give him a million dollars i'll
give it to him right now
you know because this man is always
there he's always supportive and he is
one of our shining so same thing with
hector i know i'm i'm like probably
bloviating uh towards him right now but
you got to give these people their roses
while they are here yeah and he does
tremendous work
and a lot of things people is the thing
that people
actions do all right not just his words
he's
present yes and i respect that because
showing up is 90 of the job facts
all right so slow-mo love you brother um
division's dead oh my god damn
damn wow it is it it is this
i i will freely admit guess what
destiny's doing
he's living disappointing y'all that's
what he was doing
what i told you the prophet xbox is
spoken
he had to be messy with that that's
right he's going two years since the pvp
man
let's go next week is a new destiny
situation is going to be happening
and david what's going to happen with
y'all
i still
that's actually good i like the
transformers reference that was actually
really good
anyway you have anything you said it
will be make sure you get all your bars
off too
are you good cake yeah we're good all
right no last thing that i didn't you
don't want to leave
me yo i'll leave you alone that i did
forgot
right now y'all some new log net flavors
is up there go get that you know what
i'm saying
yeah we'll get there i'll get the last
one i want to get them this yo get that
the unity
collection is up we got those log net
tumblers you know what i'm saying we got
that pint glass
you know what i'm saying we got a little
drink got the lords out there we got
some new merch coming man it's gonna be
addy king's working on some stuff
we got a lot of fun stuff so go check
out that teespring store
i'll put the link in there it's pinned
actually on the top of the page to go
check that out oh
what's up what's up let me tell you
something guys um
go to that store we're going to start
rotating the merch
yeah so a certain stuff is going to come
out of the store
all right so we're going to give a
discount for a week right before we uh
put in the new merch now our mainstays
is our logos and stuff like that that
stuff is always going to say
same price it's going to stay that way
but some of our specialty t-shirts where
is the lords and stuff like
that and the banner of the lords and
stuff if you don't purchase these
t-shirts they will go away and never
come back
all right so we have new sayings coming
up we got a little man coming up we have
all natty coming up
and you know i might get a nasty day or
something
crazy those those things are going to go
up there and we want to give you guys
back stuff that um
actually uh make you laugh and when you
put it on you know people can have
conversation pieces with you
and and being that when you're in a
patreon this is why we encourage people
to be in the patreon because we do
giveaways and stuff like that so yeah
if you happen to get a merch and you
you're able to get a free t-shirt
that's a conversational piece that's
something that you can have that we give
them back to you so we do appreciate you
guys and we're doing
more stuff in the background with the
patreons
so you guys can see us playing games
because that sea of thieves stuff was
amazing i would love to do chivalry
uh i would love to do that again i love
you um and other games like that of that
such
but again we're looking for stuff to
give you guys
to make sure that you feel that we're
giving you value we don't want you
to do like sony guys are doing and
leaving the suspensions
we're trying to gain passion and we're
trying to put back in
and keep you there oh my god thank you
i'm sorry for comparing us today
let me get the final super chat man it's
messy uh donald taco with the final
super chat
this episode going a little too short i
need y'all to go at least two more hours
yo he out of control no it did oh let's
shout out the old mentor the homie who
shouted me
out got the picture of me on tv new york
who found out
you son of a dude
spiderman fight out of super chat i'd
want lord addicts voicing halo
multiplayer so when i win and i and the
other players quit
i can hear bye
that's actually uh lucas too yeah that's
the last anyway look we out of here
everybody enjoy your sunday king did i
get your balls off to get everything off
yes bye bye we outta here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
ah